I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hi, folks. Hello, everybody. I'm sorry. I feel like I just shouted. I won't do that again. If you shouted, then what did I do? I don't know. I don't know. I'll pull back. We're a little amped up today, guys. We're excited about this episode. We're amped up. We're excited about this episode. Also, seeing my BFF's face and Sam and Cody, like the four
I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hi, folks. Hello, everybody. I'm sorry. I feel like I just shouted. I won't do that again. If you shouted, then what did I do? I don't know. I don't know. I'll pull back. We're a little amped up today, guys. We're excited about this episode. We're amped up. We're excited about this episode. Also, seeing my BFF's face and Sam and Cody, like the four|||I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hi, folks. Hello, everybody. I'm sorry. I feel like I just shouted. I won't do that again. If you shouted, then what did I do? I don't know. I don't know. I'll pull back. We're a little amped up today, guys. We're excited about this episode. We're amped up. We're excited about this episode. Also, seeing my BFF's face and Sam and Cody, like the four
of us, is kind of just like one of the highlights of my week. Every week. It's one of the highlights of my week. Yeah, it's true. Let's talk about The Office. This week's episode is Branch Closing. It is season three, episode seven, written by Mike Shore and directed by Tucker Gates. Yes. Tucker Gates directed four episodes, one of which people, like, absolutely flip out over is the Threat Level Midnight. We'll get there. Yes. Oh, yes. All right. Here's a summary for this episode, jumping right in. Jan tells Michael that the Dunder Mifflin Scranton Branch is shutting down. Michael, of course, shares this news with the rest of the office, even though Jan told him not to. I mean, what are you going to tell Michael
of us, is kind of just like one of the highlights of my week. Every week. It's one of the highlights of my week. Yeah, it's true. Let's talk about The Office. This week's episode is Branch Closing. It is season three, episode seven, written by Mike Shore and directed by Tucker Gates. Yes. Tucker Gates directed four episodes, one of which people, like, absolutely flip out over is the Threat Level Midnight. We'll get there. Yes. Oh, yes. All right. Here's a summary for this episode, jumping right in. Jan tells Michael that the Dunder Mifflin Scranton Branch is shutting down. Michael, of course, shares this news with the rest of the office, even though Jan told him not to. I mean, what are you going to tell Michael|||of us, is kind of just like one of the highlights of my week. Every week. It's one of the highlights of my week. Yeah, it's true. Let's talk about The Office. This week's episode is Branch Closing. It is season three, episode seven, written by Mike Shore and directed by Tucker Gates. Yes. Tucker Gates directed four episodes, one of which people, like, absolutely flip out over is the Threat Level Midnight. We'll get there. Yes. Oh, yes. All right. Here's a summary for this episode, jumping right in. Jan tells Michael that the Dunder Mifflin Scranton Branch is shutting down. Michael, of course, shares this news with the rest of the office, even though Jan told him not to. I mean, what are you going to tell Michael
something and expect him not to just blurt it out? He's like emotion driven. The guy cannot hold anything in. No, he can. He can hold nothing, basically. Yeah. So everyone is wondering what their new life will be like. They're talking about it. They're thinking about it. Meanwhile, Michael and Dwight drive to David Wallace's house in hopes of ambushing him and saving the branch. They're going to, they're going to save us, guys. Even if they have to be aggressive, like, what they're going to show up at this guy's house, what are they thinking? Yeah. Thank God he didn't come home. Well, we eventually learned that Josh from Stanford leveraged his position to get a new job at Staples and the Stamford
something and expect him not to just blurt it out? He's like emotion driven. The guy cannot hold anything in. No, he can. He can hold nothing, basically. Yeah. So everyone is wondering what their new life will be like. They're talking about it. They're thinking about it. Meanwhile, Michael and Dwight drive to David Wallace's house in hopes of ambushing him and saving the branch. They're going to, they're going to save us, guys. Even if they have to be aggressive, like, what they're going to show up at this guy's house, what are they thinking? Yeah. Thank God he didn't come home. Well, we eventually learned that Josh from Stanford leveraged his position to get a new job at Staples and the Stamford|||something and expect him not to just blurt it out? He's like emotion driven. The guy cannot hold anything in. No, he can. He can hold nothing, basically. Yeah. So everyone is wondering what their new life will be like. They're talking about it. They're thinking about it. Meanwhile, Michael and Dwight drive to David Wallace's house in hopes of ambushing him and saving the branch. They're going to, they're going to save us, guys. Even if they have to be aggressive, like, what they're going to show up at this guy's house, what are they thinking? Yeah. Thank God he didn't come home. Well, we eventually learned that Josh from Stanford leveraged his position to get a new job at Staples and the Stamford
Branch will now be closing. The Scranton Branch will absorb some of their employees, which means, guys, Jim is coming back. Oh, Jim is coming back. It's a big episode. That's a lot of information we find out in this episode. So much information and it sets up the rest of the season, really. It really does. Yeah. We're going to, and this is, we're going to get our new characters now. Ed Helms, Rashida Jones, Angela, we're finally next week going to be able to interact with those Stamford people. Yeah. And they really, they really get under people's skin. It's so fun. All right. But we're getting ahead. We're getting ahead of ourselves. Jenna, now you and I were being chatty on the phone yesterday. Jenna,
Branch will now be closing. The Scranton Branch will absorb some of their employees, which means, guys, Jim is coming back. Oh, Jim is coming back. It's a big episode. That's a lot of information we find out in this episode. So much information and it sets up the rest of the season, really. It really does. Yeah. We're going to, and this is, we're going to get our new characters now. Ed Helms, Rashida Jones, Angela, we're finally next week going to be able to interact with those Stamford people. Yeah. And they really, they really get under people's skin. It's so fun. All right. But we're getting ahead. We're getting ahead of ourselves. Jenna, now you and I were being chatty on the phone yesterday. Jenna,|||Branch will now be closing. The Scranton Branch will absorb some of their employees, which means, guys, Jim is coming back. Oh, Jim is coming back. It's a big episode. That's a lot of information we find out in this episode. So much information and it sets up the rest of the season, really. It really does. Yeah. We're going to, and this is, we're going to get our new characters now. Ed Helms, Rashida Jones, Angela, we're finally next week going to be able to interact with those Stamford people. Yeah. And they really, they really get under people's skin. It's so fun. All right. But we're getting ahead. We're getting ahead of ourselves. Jenna, now you and I were being chatty on the phone yesterday. Jenna,
you were a little, I don't know, braggy to me on the phone yesterday. You said you had fantastic fast facts. You wouldn't tell me. So what do you got? What do you got? You were a little braggy. I was a little braggy because I am actually really proud of these fast facts. The first one is a little soft. I'm going to just preface it now that we've built it up. But fast fact number one is that this episode of Branch Closing, it now streams it as a super sized episode. It's longer than a regular episode. It runs about 30 minutes. But when it first aired, it was a regular episode. This ran on NBC as a shorter episode. But immediately following the airing on television, NBC released what they called a producer's
you were a little, I don't know, braggy to me on the phone yesterday. You said you had fantastic fast facts. You wouldn't tell me. So what do you got? What do you got? You were a little braggy. I was a little braggy because I am actually really proud of these fast facts. The first one is a little soft. I'm going to just preface it now that we've built it up. But fast fact number one is that this episode of Branch Closing, it now streams it as a super sized episode. It's longer than a regular episode. It runs about 30 minutes. But when it first aired, it was a regular episode. This ran on NBC as a shorter episode. But immediately following the airing on television, NBC released what they called a producer's|||you were a little, I don't know, braggy to me on the phone yesterday. You said you had fantastic fast facts. You wouldn't tell me. So what do you got? What do you got? You were a little braggy. I was a little braggy because I am actually really proud of these fast facts. The first one is a little soft. I'm going to just preface it now that we've built it up. But fast fact number one is that this episode of Branch Closing, it now streams it as a super sized episode. It's longer than a regular episode. It runs about 30 minutes. But when it first aired, it was a regular episode. This ran on NBC as a shorter episode. But immediately following the airing on television, NBC released what they called a producer's
cut where they put back some deleted scenes. And that is the version that now streams today, this producer's cut. Lady, that's a very solid first fast fact. Oh, well, thank you so much. Yeah, that's really good. Thank you so much. I forgot that. I forgot that. And when I watched it, I noticed it was longer. And I was like, we always had a big announcement about our super sized episodes. Remember, it was always usually at the end of the season. And I was like, how did this one get in there? That's how. Okay. First of all, I think that this really speaks to how much stuff we used to cut from episodes. Because when you watch this episode, it feels awesome. You're like, oh, yes. And
cut where they put back some deleted scenes. And that is the version that now streams today, this producer's cut. Lady, that's a very solid first fast fact. Oh, well, thank you so much. Yeah, that's really good. Thank you so much. I forgot that. I forgot that. And when I watched it, I noticed it was longer. And I was like, we always had a big announcement about our super sized episodes. Remember, it was always usually at the end of the season. And I was like, how did this one get in there? That's how. Okay. First of all, I think that this really speaks to how much stuff we used to cut from episodes. Because when you watch this episode, it feels awesome. You're like, oh, yes. And|||cut where they put back some deleted scenes. And that is the version that now streams today, this producer's cut. Lady, that's a very solid first fast fact. Oh, well, thank you so much. Yeah, that's really good. Thank you so much. I forgot that. I forgot that. And when I watched it, I noticed it was longer. And I was like, we always had a big announcement about our super sized episodes. Remember, it was always usually at the end of the season. And I was like, how did this one get in there? That's how. Okay. First of all, I think that this really speaks to how much stuff we used to cut from episodes. Because when you watch this episode, it feels awesome. You're like, oh, yes. And
it kind of shows all the things that we used to have to cut out. And as we go along, I'll point out some of the things that only got to stay in because of this added time. I'll mention the things that were cut for the network airing. But I think this also speaks to a time historically when websites and the idea of web traffic or exclusive web content, it was just blowing up. This is the very first kind of exclusive web content of the office that NBC put out, this producer's cut. And it was because NBC wanted to drive traffic to their website. Yes. Which is also why we did those webisodes. We started doing more and more content for NBC.com. I started doing a thing called Adventures with Angela, where I would go around the set and
it kind of shows all the things that we used to have to cut out. And as we go along, I'll point out some of the things that only got to stay in because of this added time. I'll mention the things that were cut for the network airing. But I think this also speaks to a time historically when websites and the idea of web traffic or exclusive web content, it was just blowing up. This is the very first kind of exclusive web content of the office that NBC put out, this producer's cut. And it was because NBC wanted to drive traffic to their website. Yes. Which is also why we did those webisodes. We started doing more and more content for NBC.com. I started doing a thing called Adventures with Angela, where I would go around the set and|||it kind of shows all the things that we used to have to cut out. And as we go along, I'll point out some of the things that only got to stay in because of this added time. I'll mention the things that were cut for the network airing. But I think this also speaks to a time historically when websites and the idea of web traffic or exclusive web content, it was just blowing up. This is the very first kind of exclusive web content of the office that NBC put out, this producer's cut. And it was because NBC wanted to drive traffic to their website. Yes. Which is also why we did those webisodes. We started doing more and more content for NBC.com. I started doing a thing called Adventures with Angela, where I would go around the set and
make these videos and they put it on NBC.com. Because they were really starting to see, hey, this internet thing is probably going to be the way to go. And this was still before social media. This was still before Instagram. Twitter was around, but it was very much just starting. And it wasn't what it is today. But yeah, this now you almost expected. I feel like now you watch a television program and you're like, where's my extra content? Where's my behind the scenes? Where's my extended cuts? But this was like just the very beginning and branch closing was part of that. I find that fascinating, Jenna. And also, yeah, you're right. This is a time stamp, right? If we're tracking old tech, our show started before there was streaming.
make these videos and they put it on NBC.com. Because they were really starting to see, hey, this internet thing is probably going to be the way to go. And this was still before social media. This was still before Instagram. Twitter was around, but it was very much just starting. And it wasn't what it is today. But yeah, this now you almost expected. I feel like now you watch a television program and you're like, where's my extra content? Where's my behind the scenes? Where's my extended cuts? But this was like just the very beginning and branch closing was part of that. I find that fascinating, Jenna. And also, yeah, you're right. This is a time stamp, right? If we're tracking old tech, our show started before there was streaming.|||make these videos and they put it on NBC.com. Because they were really starting to see, hey, this internet thing is probably going to be the way to go. And this was still before social media. This was still before Instagram. Twitter was around, but it was very much just starting. And it wasn't what it is today. But yeah, this now you almost expected. I feel like now you watch a television program and you're like, where's my extra content? Where's my behind the scenes? Where's my extended cuts? But this was like just the very beginning and branch closing was part of that. I find that fascinating, Jenna. And also, yeah, you're right. This is a time stamp, right? If we're tracking old tech, our show started before there was streaming.
Oh, Angela. Fast fact number two is a major old tech tracking. You're going to love this. What? All right. On January 9th, 2007, Apple introduced the first iPhone. I don't know if you remember this, but it was unveiled during a presentation by Steve Jobs. We got some mail from Aaron McDonald with what might be my favorite tip off ever. He said that the cold open from this episode was the first ever piece of video played on the iPhone, and it was done during that presentation by Steve Jobs. Wow. We were part of this global moment, like without even knowing it. It blew my mind. Here is something even more crazy. I watched the whole presentation also during the presentation. Steve Jobs, when he's showing you how the music stuff works, he plays the
Oh, Angela. Fast fact number two is a major old tech tracking. You're going to love this. What? All right. On January 9th, 2007, Apple introduced the first iPhone. I don't know if you remember this, but it was unveiled during a presentation by Steve Jobs. We got some mail from Aaron McDonald with what might be my favorite tip off ever. He said that the cold open from this episode was the first ever piece of video played on the iPhone, and it was done during that presentation by Steve Jobs. Wow. We were part of this global moment, like without even knowing it. It blew my mind. Here is something even more crazy. I watched the whole presentation also during the presentation. Steve Jobs, when he's showing you how the music stuff works, he plays the|||Oh, Angela. Fast fact number two is a major old tech tracking. You're going to love this. What? All right. On January 9th, 2007, Apple introduced the first iPhone. I don't know if you remember this, but it was unveiled during a presentation by Steve Jobs. We got some mail from Aaron McDonald with what might be my favorite tip off ever. He said that the cold open from this episode was the first ever piece of video played on the iPhone, and it was done during that presentation by Steve Jobs. Wow. We were part of this global moment, like without even knowing it. It blew my mind. Here is something even more crazy. I watched the whole presentation also during the presentation. Steve Jobs, when he's showing you how the music stuff works, he plays the
Green Day song Boulevard of Broken Dreams. Angela, in season six of The Office, Dwight and Andy sing Boulevard of Broken Dreams in the Secret Santa episode. What are you trying to tell me, Jenna? What is happening? Is this an episode of Lost? Is this an episode of Lost? Group Mind. Group Mind's Time Portal. What's happening? I don't know. Don't you think it's crazy that both a video of The Office and that Green Day song were both part of this presentation, and then later that same Green Day song shows up on The Office? It's so many coincidences. What's happening? I think it's a collective of amazing creative minds. It's a group mind of great stuff. You've got an iPhone. You've got The Office. You've got
Green Day song Boulevard of Broken Dreams. Angela, in season six of The Office, Dwight and Andy sing Boulevard of Broken Dreams in the Secret Santa episode. What are you trying to tell me, Jenna? What is happening? Is this an episode of Lost? Is this an episode of Lost? Group Mind. Group Mind's Time Portal. What's happening? I don't know. Don't you think it's crazy that both a video of The Office and that Green Day song were both part of this presentation, and then later that same Green Day song shows up on The Office? It's so many coincidences. What's happening? I think it's a collective of amazing creative minds. It's a group mind of great stuff. You've got an iPhone. You've got The Office. You've got|||Green Day song Boulevard of Broken Dreams. Angela, in season six of The Office, Dwight and Andy sing Boulevard of Broken Dreams in the Secret Santa episode. What are you trying to tell me, Jenna? What is happening? Is this an episode of Lost? Is this an episode of Lost? Group Mind. Group Mind's Time Portal. What's happening? I don't know. Don't you think it's crazy that both a video of The Office and that Green Day song were both part of this presentation, and then later that same Green Day song shows up on The Office? It's so many coincidences. What's happening? I think it's a collective of amazing creative minds. It's a group mind of great stuff. You've got an iPhone. You've got The Office. You've got
Green Day. It's Group Mind. I don't know. Okay. All right. What's next, Jenna? Fast fact number three. There are a ton of talking heads in this episode. Did you notice? Well, yeah, because everyone's reacting. I did notice that. Everyone's talking about, oh, what am I going to do now that the branch is closing? And then when we find out the branch is not closing, everybody talks about, oh, here's my reaction to that news. Do you remember when we talked about how our cinematographer Randall Einhorn chose the placement of a talking head based on whether or not people had a future outside of Dunder Mifflin? Yes. To refresh everyone's memories, we learned that most characters have the Office of Dunder Mifflin behind them, behind them in that window
Green Day. It's Group Mind. I don't know. Okay. All right. What's next, Jenna? Fast fact number three. There are a ton of talking heads in this episode. Did you notice? Well, yeah, because everyone's reacting. I did notice that. Everyone's talking about, oh, what am I going to do now that the branch is closing? And then when we find out the branch is not closing, everybody talks about, oh, here's my reaction to that news. Do you remember when we talked about how our cinematographer Randall Einhorn chose the placement of a talking head based on whether or not people had a future outside of Dunder Mifflin? Yes. To refresh everyone's memories, we learned that most characters have the Office of Dunder Mifflin behind them, behind them in that window|||Green Day. It's Group Mind. I don't know. Okay. All right. What's next, Jenna? Fast fact number three. There are a ton of talking heads in this episode. Did you notice? Well, yeah, because everyone's reacting. I did notice that. Everyone's talking about, oh, what am I going to do now that the branch is closing? And then when we find out the branch is not closing, everybody talks about, oh, here's my reaction to that news. Do you remember when we talked about how our cinematographer Randall Einhorn chose the placement of a talking head based on whether or not people had a future outside of Dunder Mifflin? Yes. To refresh everyone's memories, we learned that most characters have the Office of Dunder Mifflin behind them, behind them in that window
as they're giving their talking heads. And the reason behind this was that that meant people were stuck. They didn't really have a future. They were kind of stuck in the world of Dunder Mifflin. Right. However, very often Jim would have a talking head all the time and his talking heads had a window to the world behind him. Yes. The point of that was because he had a future outside of this company. Yes. He was going places. Yes. Angela, in this episode, after the employees get the news that Dunder Mifflin Scranton is closing, every single one of the talking heads have a window to the outside world behind them. No, they don't. Oh, yes, they do. What? Wait. When they find out that the branch isn't closing, all of the talking heads switch back to having
as they're giving their talking heads. And the reason behind this was that that meant people were stuck. They didn't really have a future. They were kind of stuck in the world of Dunder Mifflin. Right. However, very often Jim would have a talking head all the time and his talking heads had a window to the world behind him. Yes. The point of that was because he had a future outside of this company. Yes. He was going places. Yes. Angela, in this episode, after the employees get the news that Dunder Mifflin Scranton is closing, every single one of the talking heads have a window to the outside world behind them. No, they don't. Oh, yes, they do. What? Wait. When they find out that the branch isn't closing, all of the talking heads switch back to having|||as they're giving their talking heads. And the reason behind this was that that meant people were stuck. They didn't really have a future. They were kind of stuck in the world of Dunder Mifflin. Right. However, very often Jim would have a talking head all the time and his talking heads had a window to the world behind him. Yes. The point of that was because he had a future outside of this company. Yes. He was going places. Yes. Angela, in this episode, after the employees get the news that Dunder Mifflin Scranton is closing, every single one of the talking heads have a window to the outside world behind them. No, they don't. Oh, yes, they do. What? Wait. When they find out that the branch isn't closing, all of the talking heads switch back to having
the bullpen behind them. I did not catch that. You have to watch it. I have to go back and watch it. Angela, you have a talking head where you're talking about Dunder Mifflin closing and outside world behind you. Same with Pam, same with Ryan, same with Phyllis, same with Stanley. And then when we find out that we're still stuck at Dunder Mifflin, Dunder Mifflin is behind us. That is so wild because I really don't think I ever had talking heads on that wall. I mean, I'm trying to think back. I think maybe one time when I was sitting next to you and we were both pregnant, right? Yeah. But like, wow, Jenna, that is a fantastic, fast fact. It's subtle, but it's layered and it's there. Everybody watch branch closing again just for the talking head.
the bullpen behind them. I did not catch that. You have to watch it. I have to go back and watch it. Angela, you have a talking head where you're talking about Dunder Mifflin closing and outside world behind you. Same with Pam, same with Ryan, same with Phyllis, same with Stanley. And then when we find out that we're still stuck at Dunder Mifflin, Dunder Mifflin is behind us. That is so wild because I really don't think I ever had talking heads on that wall. I mean, I'm trying to think back. I think maybe one time when I was sitting next to you and we were both pregnant, right? Yeah. But like, wow, Jenna, that is a fantastic, fast fact. It's subtle, but it's layered and it's there. Everybody watch branch closing again just for the talking head.|||the bullpen behind them. I did not catch that. You have to watch it. I have to go back and watch it. Angela, you have a talking head where you're talking about Dunder Mifflin closing and outside world behind you. Same with Pam, same with Ryan, same with Phyllis, same with Stanley. And then when we find out that we're still stuck at Dunder Mifflin, Dunder Mifflin is behind us. That is so wild because I really don't think I ever had talking heads on that wall. I mean, I'm trying to think back. I think maybe one time when I was sitting next to you and we were both pregnant, right? Yeah. But like, wow, Jenna, that is a fantastic, fast fact. It's subtle, but it's layered and it's there. Everybody watch branch closing again just for the talking head.
That's it. That's what I got. I'm giving you some claps all around. I was really proud of that one because I trashed that one myself. So I'm giving myself a real pat on the back. I'm raising my glass to myself. I don't know if you can see. I'm raising my coffee mug to myself. I'm raising mine back to you. You do as you raise your coffee mug. I noticed you have a tattoo on your wrist that you normally don't have. I was fascinated and fixated on it. Did your kids give you a sticky tattoo? You know, Angela, in this pandemic, we have brought back some real oldies, but goodies at our house. And one of them has been the temporary tattoos. This is something my kids were interested in when they were like two or three years old.
That's it. That's what I got. I'm giving you some claps all around. I was really proud of that one because I trashed that one myself. So I'm giving myself a real pat on the back. I'm raising my glass to myself. I don't know if you can see. I'm raising my coffee mug to myself. I'm raising mine back to you. You do as you raise your coffee mug. I noticed you have a tattoo on your wrist that you normally don't have. I was fascinated and fixated on it. Did your kids give you a sticky tattoo? You know, Angela, in this pandemic, we have brought back some real oldies, but goodies at our house. And one of them has been the temporary tattoos. This is something my kids were interested in when they were like two or three years old.|||That's it. That's what I got. I'm giving you some claps all around. I was really proud of that one because I trashed that one myself. So I'm giving myself a real pat on the back. I'm raising my glass to myself. I don't know if you can see. I'm raising my coffee mug to myself. I'm raising mine back to you. You do as you raise your coffee mug. I noticed you have a tattoo on your wrist that you normally don't have. I was fascinated and fixated on it. Did your kids give you a sticky tattoo? You know, Angela, in this pandemic, we have brought back some real oldies, but goodies at our house. And one of them has been the temporary tattoos. This is something my kids were interested in when they were like two or three years old.
And they're now eight and six. And we found this drawer of temporary tattoos and we're tattin' up. You know what? We found one as exciting as your tattoos. We found in the shed a bin of unopened Play-Doh. And it was still good. Our kids are 12, 12 and 10. They're not, you know, that's when you sort of phase out a Play-Doh. They brought it back. There's a chicken that poops Play-Doh. It's made a comeback. Lady, those fast facts were so good. I mean, where do we go from there? We should probably take a break. Let's take a break and then we'll dive into this episode. It sounds great. All right, we're back, guys. We're going to start breaking down this episode of Branch Closing. We're going to start with that cold open that
And they're now eight and six. And we found this drawer of temporary tattoos and we're tattin' up. You know what? We found one as exciting as your tattoos. We found in the shed a bin of unopened Play-Doh. And it was still good. Our kids are 12, 12 and 10. They're not, you know, that's when you sort of phase out a Play-Doh. They brought it back. There's a chicken that poops Play-Doh. It's made a comeback. Lady, those fast facts were so good. I mean, where do we go from there? We should probably take a break. Let's take a break and then we'll dive into this episode. It sounds great. All right, we're back, guys. We're going to start breaking down this episode of Branch Closing. We're going to start with that cold open that|||And they're now eight and six. And we found this drawer of temporary tattoos and we're tattin' up. You know what? We found one as exciting as your tattoos. We found in the shed a bin of unopened Play-Doh. And it was still good. Our kids are 12, 12 and 10. They're not, you know, that's when you sort of phase out a Play-Doh. They brought it back. There's a chicken that poops Play-Doh. It's made a comeback. Lady, those fast facts were so good. I mean, where do we go from there? We should probably take a break. Let's take a break and then we'll dive into this episode. It sounds great. All right, we're back, guys. We're going to start breaking down this episode of Branch Closing. We're going to start with that cold open that
we told you ran during the unveiling of the iPhone. Yeah. So this is a classic Jim prank. He has found a way to prank Dwight even from the Stanford branch. He is sending a fax very early in the morning. Karen enters. She's a little curious like, what are you doing? And he's like, it's too hard to explain. And we see a talking head where Jim says that he stole some of Dwight's stationary before he left. And he occasionally sends Dwight a fax from Dwight's future self. It's so good. It's so perfect. It's so perfect. And that morning he said, don't drink the coffee, might be poisoned, right? Something to that effect. So Dwight's like, oh my God. And he sees Stanley about to take a sip of coffee. And he practically tackles him to the ground. He's like,
we told you ran during the unveiling of the iPhone. Yeah. So this is a classic Jim prank. He has found a way to prank Dwight even from the Stanford branch. He is sending a fax very early in the morning. Karen enters. She's a little curious like, what are you doing? And he's like, it's too hard to explain. And we see a talking head where Jim says that he stole some of Dwight's stationary before he left. And he occasionally sends Dwight a fax from Dwight's future self. It's so good. It's so perfect. It's so perfect. And that morning he said, don't drink the coffee, might be poisoned, right? Something to that effect. So Dwight's like, oh my God. And he sees Stanley about to take a sip of coffee. And he practically tackles him to the ground. He's like,|||we told you ran during the unveiling of the iPhone. Yeah. So this is a classic Jim prank. He has found a way to prank Dwight even from the Stanford branch. He is sending a fax very early in the morning. Karen enters. She's a little curious like, what are you doing? And he's like, it's too hard to explain. And we see a talking head where Jim says that he stole some of Dwight's stationary before he left. And he occasionally sends Dwight a fax from Dwight's future self. It's so good. It's so perfect. It's so perfect. And that morning he said, don't drink the coffee, might be poisoned, right? Something to that effect. So Dwight's like, oh my God. And he sees Stanley about to take a sip of coffee. And he practically tackles him to the ground. He's like,
you'll thank me later. So Dwight thinks he is getting faxes from his future self. This is classic Jim. It's so good. The first thing I thought after I watched this cold open was, did Mike sure write this episode? He did, because that's Mike's shirt. This is 100% from the brain of Mike Shore. He did such a good job of writing these Jim Dwight pranks. Oh, he's so smart, Jenna. He's so smart. I know. He's smarty. Yeah. All right. So then we move into the episode and Michael is at his desk. Jan enters. Oh, Michael. Again, like three hellos. Just call me Levinson in the morning. And you know, Jan has news to deliver. But first she has to sit through this barrage of awkward hellos from Michael. And she finally tells him, Dunder Mifflin Scranton is closing.
you'll thank me later. So Dwight thinks he is getting faxes from his future self. This is classic Jim. It's so good. The first thing I thought after I watched this cold open was, did Mike sure write this episode? He did, because that's Mike's shirt. This is 100% from the brain of Mike Shore. He did such a good job of writing these Jim Dwight pranks. Oh, he's so smart, Jenna. He's so smart. I know. He's smarty. Yeah. All right. So then we move into the episode and Michael is at his desk. Jan enters. Oh, Michael. Again, like three hellos. Just call me Levinson in the morning. And you know, Jan has news to deliver. But first she has to sit through this barrage of awkward hellos from Michael. And she finally tells him, Dunder Mifflin Scranton is closing.|||you'll thank me later. So Dwight thinks he is getting faxes from his future self. This is classic Jim. It's so good. The first thing I thought after I watched this cold open was, did Mike sure write this episode? He did, because that's Mike's shirt. This is 100% from the brain of Mike Shore. He did such a good job of writing these Jim Dwight pranks. Oh, he's so smart, Jenna. He's so smart. I know. He's smarty. Yeah. All right. So then we move into the episode and Michael is at his desk. Jan enters. Oh, Michael. Again, like three hellos. Just call me Levinson in the morning. And you know, Jan has news to deliver. But first she has to sit through this barrage of awkward hellos from Michael. And she finally tells him, Dunder Mifflin Scranton is closing.
You are a severance package person. Yeah, you're not going to make it. Michael starts crying. Good. And then he starts like moaning. Like how, Jenna, can you imagine like in this moment? No. And of course, it's so loud. Everyone from outside the office can see and hear that something is going down in his office. Everyone's very curious. Yes, because he's like, like he's moaning. Kevin comes over to Pam's desk wants to know what's going on. We had a fan question. Okay. I'm going to let this fan question go. And then I have a card that just says, what is it? What Hadley Horton is wondering? Why is Pam's hair different? What's up with the Lopony? Oh, that's a separate card called Lopony. Question mark. Okay. Where should we start?
You are a severance package person. Yeah, you're not going to make it. Michael starts crying. Good. And then he starts like moaning. Like how, Jenna, can you imagine like in this moment? No. And of course, it's so loud. Everyone from outside the office can see and hear that something is going down in his office. Everyone's very curious. Yes, because he's like, like he's moaning. Kevin comes over to Pam's desk wants to know what's going on. We had a fan question. Okay. I'm going to let this fan question go. And then I have a card that just says, what is it? What Hadley Horton is wondering? Why is Pam's hair different? What's up with the Lopony? Oh, that's a separate card called Lopony. Question mark. Okay. Where should we start?|||You are a severance package person. Yeah, you're not going to make it. Michael starts crying. Good. And then he starts like moaning. Like how, Jenna, can you imagine like in this moment? No. And of course, it's so loud. Everyone from outside the office can see and hear that something is going down in his office. Everyone's very curious. Yes, because he's like, like he's moaning. Kevin comes over to Pam's desk wants to know what's going on. We had a fan question. Okay. I'm going to let this fan question go. And then I have a card that just says, what is it? What Hadley Horton is wondering? Why is Pam's hair different? What's up with the Lopony? Oh, that's a separate card called Lopony. Question mark. Okay. Where should we start?
Should we start with what or Lopony? Let's start with what and then go into Lopony. Great. Pam calls Kevin Kev and then Buddy and they fist bump. What is happening? What is happening? The fist bump was a reluctant fist bump though, Ange. I know, but she's condescending. She's being totally condescending. She's trying to put him off. She's like Kev, Buddy, fist bump, leave my desk. I mean, she's trying to get through it. That's my interpretation. My interpretation was that he's like a little kid. Yeah. Yeah. So she's like, okay, okay. She's patronizing him. For sure. But you just don't often hear Pam sort of become that casual with Kevin or, you know, I feel like she saves that part of herself
Should we start with what or Lopony? Let's start with what and then go into Lopony. Great. Pam calls Kevin Kev and then Buddy and they fist bump. What is happening? What is happening? The fist bump was a reluctant fist bump though, Ange. I know, but she's condescending. She's being totally condescending. She's trying to put him off. She's like Kev, Buddy, fist bump, leave my desk. I mean, she's trying to get through it. That's my interpretation. My interpretation was that he's like a little kid. Yeah. Yeah. So she's like, okay, okay. She's patronizing him. For sure. But you just don't often hear Pam sort of become that casual with Kevin or, you know, I feel like she saves that part of herself|||Should we start with what or Lopony? Let's start with what and then go into Lopony. Great. Pam calls Kevin Kev and then Buddy and they fist bump. What is happening? What is happening? The fist bump was a reluctant fist bump though, Ange. I know, but she's condescending. She's being totally condescending. She's trying to put him off. She's like Kev, Buddy, fist bump, leave my desk. I mean, she's trying to get through it. That's my interpretation. My interpretation was that he's like a little kid. Yeah. Yeah. So she's like, okay, okay. She's patronizing him. For sure. But you just don't often hear Pam sort of become that casual with Kevin or, you know, I feel like she saves that part of herself
for Jim and everyone else. She's sort of just aloof to a little bit. So it just kind of was startling to me that in your Lopony tale. I mean, what the heck? Here's the deal with the Lopony. I think it was a swing and a miss. I wasn't crazy about it when I saw it. We were trying to change things up. You might notice as well, Pam has got a little bit of like a pinkier sparklier eyeshadow on in this episode as well and a little lip gloss. There's so much pink. She has pink eyeshadow, pink lipstick, pink sweater, but then the Lopony with the clip. Not even a ponytail holder. I can't wait. Wait, I sounded so Southern. It's very hard for me. Holder. Anyway, it's a clip holding your hair, not even a ponytail holder. Yeah. Well, the clip is humongous. Here's the thing. The conversation
for Jim and everyone else. She's sort of just aloof to a little bit. So it just kind of was startling to me that in your Lopony tale. I mean, what the heck? Here's the deal with the Lopony. I think it was a swing and a miss. I wasn't crazy about it when I saw it. We were trying to change things up. You might notice as well, Pam has got a little bit of like a pinkier sparklier eyeshadow on in this episode as well and a little lip gloss. There's so much pink. She has pink eyeshadow, pink lipstick, pink sweater, but then the Lopony with the clip. Not even a ponytail holder. I can't wait. Wait, I sounded so Southern. It's very hard for me. Holder. Anyway, it's a clip holding your hair, not even a ponytail holder. Yeah. Well, the clip is humongous. Here's the thing. The conversation|||for Jim and everyone else. She's sort of just aloof to a little bit. So it just kind of was startling to me that in your Lopony tale. I mean, what the heck? Here's the deal with the Lopony. I think it was a swing and a miss. I wasn't crazy about it when I saw it. We were trying to change things up. You might notice as well, Pam has got a little bit of like a pinkier sparklier eyeshadow on in this episode as well and a little lip gloss. There's so much pink. She has pink eyeshadow, pink lipstick, pink sweater, but then the Lopony with the clip. Not even a ponytail holder. I can't wait. Wait, I sounded so Southern. It's very hard for me. Holder. Anyway, it's a clip holding your hair, not even a ponytail holder. Yeah. Well, the clip is humongous. Here's the thing. The conversation
in hair and makeup was that Pam would be experimenting a little bit because she's going to her art classes. She's living on her own. We needed to see some physical representation of the fact that she's attempting even in small ways to break out of her shell right now, to break out of her routines. So there you go. We offer the Lopony. I'm going to say, I think you never see it again because it wasn't great. Can we just say it wasn't great? It's a clip Lopony. Yeah. A clip Lopony. Now, I kind of wish they'd really gone for it. Next week, you would have had a banana clip. Remember those things? Oh, God. They gave you like a Mohawk. Yeah. Yeah. All right. Well, it was a moment in time. It was something we tried. Unfortunately, it's there for us all to see
in hair and makeup was that Pam would be experimenting a little bit because she's going to her art classes. She's living on her own. We needed to see some physical representation of the fact that she's attempting even in small ways to break out of her shell right now, to break out of her routines. So there you go. We offer the Lopony. I'm going to say, I think you never see it again because it wasn't great. Can we just say it wasn't great? It's a clip Lopony. Yeah. A clip Lopony. Now, I kind of wish they'd really gone for it. Next week, you would have had a banana clip. Remember those things? Oh, God. They gave you like a Mohawk. Yeah. Yeah. All right. Well, it was a moment in time. It was something we tried. Unfortunately, it's there for us all to see|||in hair and makeup was that Pam would be experimenting a little bit because she's going to her art classes. She's living on her own. We needed to see some physical representation of the fact that she's attempting even in small ways to break out of her shell right now, to break out of her routines. So there you go. We offer the Lopony. I'm going to say, I think you never see it again because it wasn't great. Can we just say it wasn't great? It's a clip Lopony. Yeah. A clip Lopony. Now, I kind of wish they'd really gone for it. Next week, you would have had a banana clip. Remember those things? Oh, God. They gave you like a Mohawk. Yeah. Yeah. All right. Well, it was a moment in time. It was something we tried. Unfortunately, it's there for us all to see
again and again. Okay. Don't don't say unfortunately to me. Do you see how many Loponies my character has? Like all the crazy hair. I don't have a problem with a Lopony. I don't have a problem with a Lopony in general. I'm just saying this particular Lopony was because of the giant clip. It was odd. We're back in Michael's office and Jenna, I don't know if you've ever had to fire someone. I have or if you've ever been fired, but I couldn't imagine getting the news Michael got and Jan's like, well, you know, they believe that Josh Porter is going to have a big role in the future of the company. And Michael goes, what kind of role the king of the stupid universe? Yeah. Could you imagine like firing someone basically who's who's having this kind of a
again and again. Okay. Don't don't say unfortunately to me. Do you see how many Loponies my character has? Like all the crazy hair. I don't have a problem with a Lopony. I don't have a problem with a Lopony in general. I'm just saying this particular Lopony was because of the giant clip. It was odd. We're back in Michael's office and Jenna, I don't know if you've ever had to fire someone. I have or if you've ever been fired, but I couldn't imagine getting the news Michael got and Jan's like, well, you know, they believe that Josh Porter is going to have a big role in the future of the company. And Michael goes, what kind of role the king of the stupid universe? Yeah. Could you imagine like firing someone basically who's who's having this kind of a|||again and again. Okay. Don't don't say unfortunately to me. Do you see how many Loponies my character has? Like all the crazy hair. I don't have a problem with a Lopony. I don't have a problem with a Lopony in general. I'm just saying this particular Lopony was because of the giant clip. It was odd. We're back in Michael's office and Jenna, I don't know if you've ever had to fire someone. I have or if you've ever been fired, but I couldn't imagine getting the news Michael got and Jan's like, well, you know, they believe that Josh Porter is going to have a big role in the future of the company. And Michael goes, what kind of role the king of the stupid universe? Yeah. Could you imagine like firing someone basically who's who's having this kind of a
spiral? I mean, could you imagine firing someone or being fired and then having their wind up mechanical teeth was in the script? It was an accident. And by the way, this points to what amazing actors Steve and Malora are because they just stayed in the moment and reacted to it as if that was meant to happen. It was not meant to happen. That's brilliant. And could it be more brilliant that you're firing this guy who's so incompetent on so many levels and his clacky teeth go off? Yes. Amazing. All right. I'm going to move us along. Michael has a talking head where he says, let's see Josh find another Stanley, Phyllis or Kevin show me that farm. Show me that farm. And during that talking head, we kind of we see Creed eating his mung beans at his desk.
spiral? I mean, could you imagine firing someone or being fired and then having their wind up mechanical teeth was in the script? It was an accident. And by the way, this points to what amazing actors Steve and Malora are because they just stayed in the moment and reacted to it as if that was meant to happen. It was not meant to happen. That's brilliant. And could it be more brilliant that you're firing this guy who's so incompetent on so many levels and his clacky teeth go off? Yes. Amazing. All right. I'm going to move us along. Michael has a talking head where he says, let's see Josh find another Stanley, Phyllis or Kevin show me that farm. Show me that farm. And during that talking head, we kind of we see Creed eating his mung beans at his desk.|||spiral? I mean, could you imagine firing someone or being fired and then having their wind up mechanical teeth was in the script? It was an accident. And by the way, this points to what amazing actors Steve and Malora are because they just stayed in the moment and reacted to it as if that was meant to happen. It was not meant to happen. That's brilliant. And could it be more brilliant that you're firing this guy who's so incompetent on so many levels and his clacky teeth go off? Yes. Amazing. All right. I'm going to move us along. Michael has a talking head where he says, let's see Josh find another Stanley, Phyllis or Kevin show me that farm. Show me that farm. And during that talking head, we kind of we see Creed eating his mung beans at his desk.
We see Phyllis knitting and we had a fan question from Stephanie Miller. In this episode, when we see Phyllis knitting, can she knit in real life? Did she knit that whole scarf her character is working on? You guys, she is 100% fake knitting. Phyllis cannot knit. Didn't she do so good? They had a basket full of knitting stuff. They'd made it part of her character. It's set next to her desk all nine seasons. And it just sat there. And sometimes if she had to do background stuff, but this was a great panning shot because, you know, Michael says there is no Stanley tree and he's napping. And then they said, do you think the world is crawling with Phyllis's and she's knitting? So it was this great visual. But no, Phyllis can't knit. Yeah. No. No, that's one of my
We see Phyllis knitting and we had a fan question from Stephanie Miller. In this episode, when we see Phyllis knitting, can she knit in real life? Did she knit that whole scarf her character is working on? You guys, she is 100% fake knitting. Phyllis cannot knit. Didn't she do so good? They had a basket full of knitting stuff. They'd made it part of her character. It's set next to her desk all nine seasons. And it just sat there. And sometimes if she had to do background stuff, but this was a great panning shot because, you know, Michael says there is no Stanley tree and he's napping. And then they said, do you think the world is crawling with Phyllis's and she's knitting? So it was this great visual. But no, Phyllis can't knit. Yeah. No. No, that's one of my|||We see Phyllis knitting and we had a fan question from Stephanie Miller. In this episode, when we see Phyllis knitting, can she knit in real life? Did she knit that whole scarf her character is working on? You guys, she is 100% fake knitting. Phyllis cannot knit. Didn't she do so good? They had a basket full of knitting stuff. They'd made it part of her character. It's set next to her desk all nine seasons. And it just sat there. And sometimes if she had to do background stuff, but this was a great panning shot because, you know, Michael says there is no Stanley tree and he's napping. And then they said, do you think the world is crawling with Phyllis's and she's knitting? So it was this great visual. But no, Phyllis can't knit. Yeah. No. No, that's one of my
favorite talking heads though. I love that one. I do too. I do too. So then Michael is walking around the office. Dwight can tell something's wrong, but Michael isn't spilling. And this is my other favorite talking head from this episode, which is Dwight's talking head, where he says when you're close to someone, you can read them like a book. And he says Michael's book is titled Something weird is going on. Colin, what did Jan say? The Michael Scott story by Michael Scott with Dwight Schrute. Alright, that last part is not in the script. And I could kind of tell that there was an improv there because whenever rain improv's at the end of a talking head or the end of a scene, I feel like you can see him smile just a little bit in the corners of his mouth and
favorite talking heads though. I love that one. I do too. I do too. So then Michael is walking around the office. Dwight can tell something's wrong, but Michael isn't spilling. And this is my other favorite talking head from this episode, which is Dwight's talking head, where he says when you're close to someone, you can read them like a book. And he says Michael's book is titled Something weird is going on. Colin, what did Jan say? The Michael Scott story by Michael Scott with Dwight Schrute. Alright, that last part is not in the script. And I could kind of tell that there was an improv there because whenever rain improv's at the end of a talking head or the end of a scene, I feel like you can see him smile just a little bit in the corners of his mouth and|||favorite talking heads though. I love that one. I do too. I do too. So then Michael is walking around the office. Dwight can tell something's wrong, but Michael isn't spilling. And this is my other favorite talking head from this episode, which is Dwight's talking head, where he says when you're close to someone, you can read them like a book. And he says Michael's book is titled Something weird is going on. Colin, what did Jan say? The Michael Scott story by Michael Scott with Dwight Schrute. Alright, that last part is not in the script. And I could kind of tell that there was an improv there because whenever rain improv's at the end of a talking head or the end of a scene, I feel like you can see him smile just a little bit in the corners of his mouth and
his eyes. So I reached out to Mike, sure. And he told me that he and rain expanded on the book title on the day on set. They kept throwing out ideas. The original was just supposed to be something weird is going on. Colin, what did Jan say? And Mike threw out the Michael Scott story and then rain added with Dwight Schrute. Yeah, for sure. I mean, I feel like we all have tells. And rain, when he has an improv that I think he's really happy with has a little bit of a smirk. He's kind of proud of the moment. He amuses himself in the moment while saying it. Now things are really getting heightened over at the Stanford branch, because Karen breaks the news that the Scranton branch is closing to Jim. And oh, my God, Jim's face. He's like, what? You notice he doesn't
his eyes. So I reached out to Mike, sure. And he told me that he and rain expanded on the book title on the day on set. They kept throwing out ideas. The original was just supposed to be something weird is going on. Colin, what did Jan say? And Mike threw out the Michael Scott story and then rain added with Dwight Schrute. Yeah, for sure. I mean, I feel like we all have tells. And rain, when he has an improv that I think he's really happy with has a little bit of a smirk. He's kind of proud of the moment. He amuses himself in the moment while saying it. Now things are really getting heightened over at the Stanford branch, because Karen breaks the news that the Scranton branch is closing to Jim. And oh, my God, Jim's face. He's like, what? You notice he doesn't|||his eyes. So I reached out to Mike, sure. And he told me that he and rain expanded on the book title on the day on set. They kept throwing out ideas. The original was just supposed to be something weird is going on. Colin, what did Jan say? And Mike threw out the Michael Scott story and then rain added with Dwight Schrute. Yeah, for sure. I mean, I feel like we all have tells. And rain, when he has an improv that I think he's really happy with has a little bit of a smirk. He's kind of proud of the moment. He amuses himself in the moment while saying it. Now things are really getting heightened over at the Stanford branch, because Karen breaks the news that the Scranton branch is closing to Jim. And oh, my God, Jim's face. He's like, what? You notice he doesn't
reach out to Pam. Pam and Jim never call one another or text one another in this whole day. It's kind of weird because in Diwali, we see that Pam was texting Jim, and they had that phone call at the end of grief counseling. But what's going on? Why no communication? It makes perfect sense to me. You know, they're both sort of struggling with where do we go from here. And I'm sure Pam's first instinct is to reach out to him, but she doesn't feel like she has that kind of access to him anymore. She rejected him. So no, it makes perfect sense to me that they don't communicate. What I thought was weirder and we're going to get to it is that Roy finds out from accounting. So Pam didn't even
reach out to Pam. Pam and Jim never call one another or text one another in this whole day. It's kind of weird because in Diwali, we see that Pam was texting Jim, and they had that phone call at the end of grief counseling. But what's going on? Why no communication? It makes perfect sense to me. You know, they're both sort of struggling with where do we go from here. And I'm sure Pam's first instinct is to reach out to him, but she doesn't feel like she has that kind of access to him anymore. She rejected him. So no, it makes perfect sense to me that they don't communicate. What I thought was weirder and we're going to get to it is that Roy finds out from accounting. So Pam didn't even|||reach out to Pam. Pam and Jim never call one another or text one another in this whole day. It's kind of weird because in Diwali, we see that Pam was texting Jim, and they had that phone call at the end of grief counseling. But what's going on? Why no communication? It makes perfect sense to me. You know, they're both sort of struggling with where do we go from here. And I'm sure Pam's first instinct is to reach out to him, but she doesn't feel like she has that kind of access to him anymore. She rejected him. So no, it makes perfect sense to me that they don't communicate. What I thought was weirder and we're going to get to it is that Roy finds out from accounting. So Pam didn't even
tell Roy. That's right. So now Michael approaches Pam at front reception. He's acting really strange. She clearly knows something is up because he was moaning in his office and Jan visited. So Pam's like, what's going on, Michael? Yeah, I have a fan catch from this moment. Okay. At six minutes, 21 seconds, Celeste Dimas says, if you freeze and look closely on that big board that's hanging by accounting on Tuesday, the fifth, it says one of many Emmys, Steve was robbed. Oh, that's a great fan catch. I promise I didn't write it. We shot this episode about two weeks after the Emmys and I guess someone had written up on the board a little congratulations to us. And we also needed to say that Steve was robbed because he
tell Roy. That's right. So now Michael approaches Pam at front reception. He's acting really strange. She clearly knows something is up because he was moaning in his office and Jan visited. So Pam's like, what's going on, Michael? Yeah, I have a fan catch from this moment. Okay. At six minutes, 21 seconds, Celeste Dimas says, if you freeze and look closely on that big board that's hanging by accounting on Tuesday, the fifth, it says one of many Emmys, Steve was robbed. Oh, that's a great fan catch. I promise I didn't write it. We shot this episode about two weeks after the Emmys and I guess someone had written up on the board a little congratulations to us. And we also needed to say that Steve was robbed because he|||tell Roy. That's right. So now Michael approaches Pam at front reception. He's acting really strange. She clearly knows something is up because he was moaning in his office and Jan visited. So Pam's like, what's going on, Michael? Yeah, I have a fan catch from this moment. Okay. At six minutes, 21 seconds, Celeste Dimas says, if you freeze and look closely on that big board that's hanging by accounting on Tuesday, the fifth, it says one of many Emmys, Steve was robbed. Oh, that's a great fan catch. I promise I didn't write it. We shot this episode about two weeks after the Emmys and I guess someone had written up on the board a little congratulations to us. And we also needed to say that Steve was robbed because he
did not win that year for Michael Scott. He never won for Michael Scott, which is ridiculous. Yeah. Yeah. Well, I have a Jenna catch because since Celeste turned me on to looking at this white board, I found something else on the white board on the top line written under Thursday, written in multiple colors. It says, in case you haven't noticed, there is a lot of colorful hooey on this board. Anyway, guys, for the future, I think it could be very fun to freeze on this white board because they did change what they wrote all the time. Well, I love that. I love the little subtle shade towards the television academy about Steve not kidding the Emmy. Totally. Coming up next, Michael has a talking head and then he does something immediately after and it's
did not win that year for Michael Scott. He never won for Michael Scott, which is ridiculous. Yeah. Yeah. Well, I have a Jenna catch because since Celeste turned me on to looking at this white board, I found something else on the white board on the top line written under Thursday, written in multiple colors. It says, in case you haven't noticed, there is a lot of colorful hooey on this board. Anyway, guys, for the future, I think it could be very fun to freeze on this white board because they did change what they wrote all the time. Well, I love that. I love the little subtle shade towards the television academy about Steve not kidding the Emmy. Totally. Coming up next, Michael has a talking head and then he does something immediately after and it's|||did not win that year for Michael Scott. He never won for Michael Scott, which is ridiculous. Yeah. Yeah. Well, I have a Jenna catch because since Celeste turned me on to looking at this white board, I found something else on the white board on the top line written under Thursday, written in multiple colors. It says, in case you haven't noticed, there is a lot of colorful hooey on this board. Anyway, guys, for the future, I think it could be very fun to freeze on this white board because they did change what they wrote all the time. Well, I love that. I love the little subtle shade towards the television academy about Steve not kidding the Emmy. Totally. Coming up next, Michael has a talking head and then he does something immediately after and it's
one of these classic Michael moments that I live for. It always makes me laugh so hard. Michael says that all he can do is put on a brave face and be our leader. And then he says to the whole bullpen, it's over. We are screwed. Yeah. Really, buddy? That's the brave face you're putting on for us? Okay, thanks. Yeah. I mean, he really, he offers no comfort. He sort of begins to ugly cry. Angela is asking about the employees, asking about their jobs. I have two catches here. I have something I need to say, Angela. Okay, go. At seven minutes, 18 seconds. You're sweater? It's a sweater vest. Okay. So I actually have some photos of this sweater from a wardrobe fitting that I saved. So I have a button-down shirt and then over it, I have a sweater vest, but it's
one of these classic Michael moments that I live for. It always makes me laugh so hard. Michael says that all he can do is put on a brave face and be our leader. And then he says to the whole bullpen, it's over. We are screwed. Yeah. Really, buddy? That's the brave face you're putting on for us? Okay, thanks. Yeah. I mean, he really, he offers no comfort. He sort of begins to ugly cry. Angela is asking about the employees, asking about their jobs. I have two catches here. I have something I need to say, Angela. Okay, go. At seven minutes, 18 seconds. You're sweater? It's a sweater vest. Okay. So I actually have some photos of this sweater from a wardrobe fitting that I saved. So I have a button-down shirt and then over it, I have a sweater vest, but it's|||one of these classic Michael moments that I live for. It always makes me laugh so hard. Michael says that all he can do is put on a brave face and be our leader. And then he says to the whole bullpen, it's over. We are screwed. Yeah. Really, buddy? That's the brave face you're putting on for us? Okay, thanks. Yeah. I mean, he really, he offers no comfort. He sort of begins to ugly cry. Angela is asking about the employees, asking about their jobs. I have two catches here. I have something I need to say, Angela. Okay, go. At seven minutes, 18 seconds. You're sweater? It's a sweater vest. Okay. So I actually have some photos of this sweater from a wardrobe fitting that I saved. So I have a button-down shirt and then over it, I have a sweater vest, but it's
like a tank. It's like a teeny, tiny, very odd sweater vest. It's like another one of those failed project runway contests. Oh, 100%. And then our wardrobe designer, Carrie Bennett, took the buttons off the sweater vest and replaced them with those cat faces. It's really a work of art. It really is. All right. Well, I have a catch at seven minutes, 27 seconds. This is one of the most famous Michael Scott memes. It's Steve making that face, like he's about to cry or maybe he smells dog poop. You know the face. And he says, this is the worst. And people use it a ton to respond to other people. Like when they get some news that they're like, no way. All of a sudden, I see in my feed Steve's face.
like a tank. It's like a teeny, tiny, very odd sweater vest. It's like another one of those failed project runway contests. Oh, 100%. And then our wardrobe designer, Carrie Bennett, took the buttons off the sweater vest and replaced them with those cat faces. It's really a work of art. It really is. All right. Well, I have a catch at seven minutes, 27 seconds. This is one of the most famous Michael Scott memes. It's Steve making that face, like he's about to cry or maybe he smells dog poop. You know the face. And he says, this is the worst. And people use it a ton to respond to other people. Like when they get some news that they're like, no way. All of a sudden, I see in my feed Steve's face.|||like a tank. It's like a teeny, tiny, very odd sweater vest. It's like another one of those failed project runway contests. Oh, 100%. And then our wardrobe designer, Carrie Bennett, took the buttons off the sweater vest and replaced them with those cat faces. It's really a work of art. It really is. All right. Well, I have a catch at seven minutes, 27 seconds. This is one of the most famous Michael Scott memes. It's Steve making that face, like he's about to cry or maybe he smells dog poop. You know the face. And he says, this is the worst. And people use it a ton to respond to other people. Like when they get some news that they're like, no way. All of a sudden, I see in my feed Steve's face.
Okay. On Office Ladies Pod, will you please post the pictures of your cat buttons and of this meme? Yes, of course. Of course. Okay, good. Because I want everyone to have these visuals. Okay. I think it's important. I have a script question, Jenna, because I know you have the scripts. So Toby admits that he knows that this was going to happen. Michael calls him a traitor, says he wants to see him in his office. They start to walk in. And Michael says, oh, my God, you walk so slowly. I feel like that was Steve improvising. I had that same feeling. And I did look at the script. None of that part of him calling Toby into his office was scripted. So that whole bit of him calling Toby in his office, say he's walking slowly and then
Okay. On Office Ladies Pod, will you please post the pictures of your cat buttons and of this meme? Yes, of course. Of course. Okay, good. Because I want everyone to have these visuals. Okay. I think it's important. I have a script question, Jenna, because I know you have the scripts. So Toby admits that he knows that this was going to happen. Michael calls him a traitor, says he wants to see him in his office. They start to walk in. And Michael says, oh, my God, you walk so slowly. I feel like that was Steve improvising. I had that same feeling. And I did look at the script. None of that part of him calling Toby into his office was scripted. So that whole bit of him calling Toby in his office, say he's walking slowly and then|||Okay. On Office Ladies Pod, will you please post the pictures of your cat buttons and of this meme? Yes, of course. Of course. Okay, good. Because I want everyone to have these visuals. Okay. I think it's important. I have a script question, Jenna, because I know you have the scripts. So Toby admits that he knows that this was going to happen. Michael calls him a traitor, says he wants to see him in his office. They start to walk in. And Michael says, oh, my God, you walk so slowly. I feel like that was Steve improvising. I had that same feeling. And I did look at the script. None of that part of him calling Toby into his office was scripted. So that whole bit of him calling Toby in his office, say he's walking slowly and then
Dwight guarding the door and putting his hand up to the camera, none of that was in the script. Amazing. Amazing. And I love that everyone just went with it. They just were like, oh, Steve's doing his thing. We're going to let this play out and participate. Because I looked, I was like, wait, is there a lost scene of Toby in Michael's office? Is there a conversation that didn't make it? No. No, that was just Steve on the day. Wow. And you know, speaking of how Rain gets the little smirk when he improvises at seven minutes, 52 seconds, when he won't let the camera crew in and he shuts the door, he has the smirk. I noticed it too. Well, we had a fan question from Mary Poulton. And actually a lot of people wrote in with
Dwight guarding the door and putting his hand up to the camera, none of that was in the script. Amazing. Amazing. And I love that everyone just went with it. They just were like, oh, Steve's doing his thing. We're going to let this play out and participate. Because I looked, I was like, wait, is there a lost scene of Toby in Michael's office? Is there a conversation that didn't make it? No. No, that was just Steve on the day. Wow. And you know, speaking of how Rain gets the little smirk when he improvises at seven minutes, 52 seconds, when he won't let the camera crew in and he shuts the door, he has the smirk. I noticed it too. Well, we had a fan question from Mary Poulton. And actually a lot of people wrote in with|||Dwight guarding the door and putting his hand up to the camera, none of that was in the script. Amazing. Amazing. And I love that everyone just went with it. They just were like, oh, Steve's doing his thing. We're going to let this play out and participate. Because I looked, I was like, wait, is there a lost scene of Toby in Michael's office? Is there a conversation that didn't make it? No. No, that was just Steve on the day. Wow. And you know, speaking of how Rain gets the little smirk when he improvises at seven minutes, 52 seconds, when he won't let the camera crew in and he shuts the door, he has the smirk. I noticed it too. Well, we had a fan question from Mary Poulton. And actually a lot of people wrote in with
a similar question. She wanted to know when we got the script for this episode, did any of us worry that the show was being canceled? Or did we know that this was just an idea for an episode? And she was asking and a lot of people were asking because we've said before sometimes plots are revealed to us at these table reads and they were shocking. And they wanted to know as we sat down and got the script as we were reading it, were we thinking, wait a second, what? Scranton's closing, are we all out of jobs? No, guys, we knew that this was a plot point. None of us were worried. We had all had our contracts renewed for all of season three. Yeah. And so we knew that we would be producing 24 episodes in season three. And we also had been
a similar question. She wanted to know when we got the script for this episode, did any of us worry that the show was being canceled? Or did we know that this was just an idea for an episode? And she was asking and a lot of people were asking because we've said before sometimes plots are revealed to us at these table reads and they were shocking. And they wanted to know as we sat down and got the script as we were reading it, were we thinking, wait a second, what? Scranton's closing, are we all out of jobs? No, guys, we knew that this was a plot point. None of us were worried. We had all had our contracts renewed for all of season three. Yeah. And so we knew that we would be producing 24 episodes in season three. And we also had been|||a similar question. She wanted to know when we got the script for this episode, did any of us worry that the show was being canceled? Or did we know that this was just an idea for an episode? And she was asking and a lot of people were asking because we've said before sometimes plots are revealed to us at these table reads and they were shocking. And they wanted to know as we sat down and got the script as we were reading it, were we thinking, wait a second, what? Scranton's closing, are we all out of jobs? No, guys, we knew that this was a plot point. None of us were worried. We had all had our contracts renewed for all of season three. Yeah. And so we knew that we would be producing 24 episodes in season three. And we also had been
tipped off to the fact that eventually there would be a merger episode and that those people from Stanford would be coming to join us. So we didn't have any kind of surprise or anxiety when we got the script. No, we were just excited because it meant finally after this episode, we could all be in one room together. So we were excited. At least the Scranton branch, we were excited. I don't know. Maybe Stanford was like, we like our schedule, but we were excited to have everyone back. All right. So now, Angela, we move into a Ryan talking head and he's holding up his business cards, right? Or are they his calling cards? Oh boy. He's holding up his business slash calling cards. Eight minutes. Notice, here it is, talking head exterior window behind him.
tipped off to the fact that eventually there would be a merger episode and that those people from Stanford would be coming to join us. So we didn't have any kind of surprise or anxiety when we got the script. No, we were just excited because it meant finally after this episode, we could all be in one room together. So we were excited. At least the Scranton branch, we were excited. I don't know. Maybe Stanford was like, we like our schedule, but we were excited to have everyone back. All right. So now, Angela, we move into a Ryan talking head and he's holding up his business cards, right? Or are they his calling cards? Oh boy. He's holding up his business slash calling cards. Eight minutes. Notice, here it is, talking head exterior window behind him.|||tipped off to the fact that eventually there would be a merger episode and that those people from Stanford would be coming to join us. So we didn't have any kind of surprise or anxiety when we got the script. No, we were just excited because it meant finally after this episode, we could all be in one room together. So we were excited. At least the Scranton branch, we were excited. I don't know. Maybe Stanford was like, we like our schedule, but we were excited to have everyone back. All right. So now, Angela, we move into a Ryan talking head and he's holding up his business cards, right? Or are they his calling cards? Oh boy. He's holding up his business slash calling cards. Eight minutes. Notice, here it is, talking head exterior window behind him.
This is the beginning of the exterior window talking heads because next up, Angela has a talking head and Kelly has a talking head with the mascara on her face, all exterior windows. She's going to track it. All right. So now we're going back to Stanford and Andy is leading everyone in a chant. Stanford, Connecticut. Right. He's getting everyone worked up. So while everyone's chanting at eight minutes, 23 seconds, you will see someone who is beloved by our office cast and crew. Her name is Lori Sox. She was our stand in her and her husband, Steven. They were like a stand in duo team and she's in the background in the scene and it just made me so happy to see her. I saw her too. I saw her too and I loved it. Well, maybe we should explain what a stand in is if we
This is the beginning of the exterior window talking heads because next up, Angela has a talking head and Kelly has a talking head with the mascara on her face, all exterior windows. She's going to track it. All right. So now we're going back to Stanford and Andy is leading everyone in a chant. Stanford, Connecticut. Right. He's getting everyone worked up. So while everyone's chanting at eight minutes, 23 seconds, you will see someone who is beloved by our office cast and crew. Her name is Lori Sox. She was our stand in her and her husband, Steven. They were like a stand in duo team and she's in the background in the scene and it just made me so happy to see her. I saw her too. I saw her too and I loved it. Well, maybe we should explain what a stand in is if we|||This is the beginning of the exterior window talking heads because next up, Angela has a talking head and Kelly has a talking head with the mascara on her face, all exterior windows. She's going to track it. All right. So now we're going back to Stanford and Andy is leading everyone in a chant. Stanford, Connecticut. Right. He's getting everyone worked up. So while everyone's chanting at eight minutes, 23 seconds, you will see someone who is beloved by our office cast and crew. Her name is Lori Sox. She was our stand in her and her husband, Steven. They were like a stand in duo team and she's in the background in the scene and it just made me so happy to see her. I saw her too. I saw her too and I loved it. Well, maybe we should explain what a stand in is if we
haven't before. So after you rehearse a scene with the actors, you bring in people to stand in for the actors while the crew sets the lights and the camera angles. And this is an opportunity for the cast to go and get their makeup fixed or change their outfit or any number of things, rehearse their lines. And then when we're ready to start rolling, the actors come back in and stand in their positions or sit at their desks. So Lori would stand in for all the women and Steven, her husband would stand in for the men. But every once in a while, you'll see them pop up in the background of scenes and that's what happened here. Yeah, they're wonderful. And we all became very close. And anyway, I was very excited to see her there. I know. They were the loveliest and they
haven't before. So after you rehearse a scene with the actors, you bring in people to stand in for the actors while the crew sets the lights and the camera angles. And this is an opportunity for the cast to go and get their makeup fixed or change their outfit or any number of things, rehearse their lines. And then when we're ready to start rolling, the actors come back in and stand in their positions or sit at their desks. So Lori would stand in for all the women and Steven, her husband would stand in for the men. But every once in a while, you'll see them pop up in the background of scenes and that's what happened here. Yeah, they're wonderful. And we all became very close. And anyway, I was very excited to see her there. I know. They were the loveliest and they|||haven't before. So after you rehearse a scene with the actors, you bring in people to stand in for the actors while the crew sets the lights and the camera angles. And this is an opportunity for the cast to go and get their makeup fixed or change their outfit or any number of things, rehearse their lines. And then when we're ready to start rolling, the actors come back in and stand in their positions or sit at their desks. So Lori would stand in for all the women and Steven, her husband would stand in for the men. But every once in a while, you'll see them pop up in the background of scenes and that's what happened here. Yeah, they're wonderful. And we all became very close. And anyway, I was very excited to see her there. I know. They were the loveliest and they
had two kids. Lori got pregnant twice over the course of the show. Everybody who worked on our show became part of the family and they were part of our family. Yes, absolutely. Well, back in Scranton, Meredith goes into Michael's office to let him know that she is still down to sleep together. She's still down to get down. Yeah, because, you know, they made a pact years ago that they would sleep together on the last day of work. And Michael is like, I have no idea what you're talking about. Okay, this storyline, which is going to keep playing out of Meredith trying to figure out who she agreed to have sex with on her last day of work. This was an example of one of the storylines that got cut from the original NBC airing. So we were able to keep
had two kids. Lori got pregnant twice over the course of the show. Everybody who worked on our show became part of the family and they were part of our family. Yes, absolutely. Well, back in Scranton, Meredith goes into Michael's office to let him know that she is still down to sleep together. She's still down to get down. Yeah, because, you know, they made a pact years ago that they would sleep together on the last day of work. And Michael is like, I have no idea what you're talking about. Okay, this storyline, which is going to keep playing out of Meredith trying to figure out who she agreed to have sex with on her last day of work. This was an example of one of the storylines that got cut from the original NBC airing. So we were able to keep|||had two kids. Lori got pregnant twice over the course of the show. Everybody who worked on our show became part of the family and they were part of our family. Yes, absolutely. Well, back in Scranton, Meredith goes into Michael's office to let him know that she is still down to sleep together. She's still down to get down. Yeah, because, you know, they made a pact years ago that they would sleep together on the last day of work. And Michael is like, I have no idea what you're talking about. Okay, this storyline, which is going to keep playing out of Meredith trying to figure out who she agreed to have sex with on her last day of work. This was an example of one of the storylines that got cut from the original NBC airing. So we were able to keep
this storyline in because we got the extra time with the producer's cut. Oh my gosh. And see, I love it. I feel like it fills out the picture. Yes, completely. Well, Jenna, your character has a pretty big talking head coming up. You know, it's interesting to see how the branch closing is affecting everyone. I mean, Stanley is elated, right? He's going to retire early. Oh yeah, Stanley is elated. Ryan says this worked out great. And Pam is really happy. Oh yeah. And we express all of those emotions with an exterior window behind us, Angela. Well, Pam says that she always thought that maybe she would make a big speech and slap someone and storm out. So dramatic. I know. Who would she slap? It would have been me. She would have slapped me.
this storyline in because we got the extra time with the producer's cut. Oh my gosh. And see, I love it. I feel like it fills out the picture. Yes, completely. Well, Jenna, your character has a pretty big talking head coming up. You know, it's interesting to see how the branch closing is affecting everyone. I mean, Stanley is elated, right? He's going to retire early. Oh yeah, Stanley is elated. Ryan says this worked out great. And Pam is really happy. Oh yeah. And we express all of those emotions with an exterior window behind us, Angela. Well, Pam says that she always thought that maybe she would make a big speech and slap someone and storm out. So dramatic. I know. Who would she slap? It would have been me. She would have slapped me.|||this storyline in because we got the extra time with the producer's cut. Oh my gosh. And see, I love it. I feel like it fills out the picture. Yes, completely. Well, Jenna, your character has a pretty big talking head coming up. You know, it's interesting to see how the branch closing is affecting everyone. I mean, Stanley is elated, right? He's going to retire early. Oh yeah, Stanley is elated. Ryan says this worked out great. And Pam is really happy. Oh yeah. And we express all of those emotions with an exterior window behind us, Angela. Well, Pam says that she always thought that maybe she would make a big speech and slap someone and storm out. So dramatic. I know. Who would she slap? It would have been me. She would have slapped me.
Well, she's eventually going to slap Michael. So maybe that's who she means. But it's definitely either you or Michael, right? Yeah. Yeah. 100%. Okay, so now, Angela, we're over an accounting. And Angela and Kevin break the news to Roy. Yeah. Why do Angela and Kevin break the news, huh? I don't know. Why hasn't Pam said anything? I think this really shows how disconnected Roy and Pam are, by the way. Well, he seems very concerned that Pam might be one of the Connecticut transfers. But Angela kind of misreads his concern and thinks that he's worrying about himself. And she's like, oh, Roy, you'll be fine. You're so strong and capable. Yeah, don't worry, Roy. Yeah, don't worry, Roy. Kevin finds this hilarious. Angela tells him to grow up.
Well, she's eventually going to slap Michael. So maybe that's who she means. But it's definitely either you or Michael, right? Yeah. Yeah. 100%. Okay, so now, Angela, we're over an accounting. And Angela and Kevin break the news to Roy. Yeah. Why do Angela and Kevin break the news, huh? I don't know. Why hasn't Pam said anything? I think this really shows how disconnected Roy and Pam are, by the way. Well, he seems very concerned that Pam might be one of the Connecticut transfers. But Angela kind of misreads his concern and thinks that he's worrying about himself. And she's like, oh, Roy, you'll be fine. You're so strong and capable. Yeah, don't worry, Roy. Yeah, don't worry, Roy. Kevin finds this hilarious. Angela tells him to grow up.|||Well, she's eventually going to slap Michael. So maybe that's who she means. But it's definitely either you or Michael, right? Yeah. Yeah. 100%. Okay, so now, Angela, we're over an accounting. And Angela and Kevin break the news to Roy. Yeah. Why do Angela and Kevin break the news, huh? I don't know. Why hasn't Pam said anything? I think this really shows how disconnected Roy and Pam are, by the way. Well, he seems very concerned that Pam might be one of the Connecticut transfers. But Angela kind of misreads his concern and thinks that he's worrying about himself. And she's like, oh, Roy, you'll be fine. You're so strong and capable. Yeah, don't worry, Roy. Yeah, don't worry, Roy. Kevin finds this hilarious. Angela tells him to grow up.
Yeah, he totally storms off. We got a fan question from Patricia Kennedy. Patricia wants to know, Angela, when you're talking to Roy, it seems like Angela has a thing for Roy. Did she? Patricia, this is a fantastic question. All right, many of you out there have speculated about Angela and Roy. Jenna, I have been asked this question a lot. And there's all of these threads online about it. So the answer, Patricia, is yes. It seems like Angela always had a thing for Roy. I love this question, Patricia, because this has given us an opportunity to track it. We're going to track this Angela Roy flirtation because it is real and it is happening. All right. Early on, there are a few episodes that kind of hint at this Roy Angela flirtation. I
Yeah, he totally storms off. We got a fan question from Patricia Kennedy. Patricia wants to know, Angela, when you're talking to Roy, it seems like Angela has a thing for Roy. Did she? Patricia, this is a fantastic question. All right, many of you out there have speculated about Angela and Roy. Jenna, I have been asked this question a lot. And there's all of these threads online about it. So the answer, Patricia, is yes. It seems like Angela always had a thing for Roy. I love this question, Patricia, because this has given us an opportunity to track it. We're going to track this Angela Roy flirtation because it is real and it is happening. All right. Early on, there are a few episodes that kind of hint at this Roy Angela flirtation. I|||Yeah, he totally storms off. We got a fan question from Patricia Kennedy. Patricia wants to know, Angela, when you're talking to Roy, it seems like Angela has a thing for Roy. Did she? Patricia, this is a fantastic question. All right, many of you out there have speculated about Angela and Roy. Jenna, I have been asked this question a lot. And there's all of these threads online about it. So the answer, Patricia, is yes. It seems like Angela always had a thing for Roy. I love this question, Patricia, because this has given us an opportunity to track it. We're going to track this Angela Roy flirtation because it is real and it is happening. All right. Early on, there are a few episodes that kind of hint at this Roy Angela flirtation. I
believe it starts in the fire. This is season two. Remember when the members of the office are playing the game, who would you do? And Michael asks Roy, who would you do? And Roy says, what's the name of that tight-ass Christian chick, the blonde? Yeah, sort of referring to Angela, right? Yeah, and I'm standing right there. And I'm like, my name is Angela. And he's like, hey, Angela. So definitely it starts there. And then in the secret, when Angela and Phyllis are in the kitchen and they're cleaning out the fridge, Phyllis asks Angela, who'd she pick if she were in Pam's shoes, Jim or Roy? And Angela's like, oh, I don't want to participate in this, right? But then she gets this kind of weird look on her face and she goes, Roy,
believe it starts in the fire. This is season two. Remember when the members of the office are playing the game, who would you do? And Michael asks Roy, who would you do? And Roy says, what's the name of that tight-ass Christian chick, the blonde? Yeah, sort of referring to Angela, right? Yeah, and I'm standing right there. And I'm like, my name is Angela. And he's like, hey, Angela. So definitely it starts there. And then in the secret, when Angela and Phyllis are in the kitchen and they're cleaning out the fridge, Phyllis asks Angela, who'd she pick if she were in Pam's shoes, Jim or Roy? And Angela's like, oh, I don't want to participate in this, right? But then she gets this kind of weird look on her face and she goes, Roy,|||believe it starts in the fire. This is season two. Remember when the members of the office are playing the game, who would you do? And Michael asks Roy, who would you do? And Roy says, what's the name of that tight-ass Christian chick, the blonde? Yeah, sort of referring to Angela, right? Yeah, and I'm standing right there. And I'm like, my name is Angela. And he's like, hey, Angela. So definitely it starts there. And then in the secret, when Angela and Phyllis are in the kitchen and they're cleaning out the fridge, Phyllis asks Angela, who'd she pick if she were in Pam's shoes, Jim or Roy? And Angela's like, oh, I don't want to participate in this, right? But then she gets this kind of weird look on her face and she goes, Roy,
Roy, weird. Look, it's like a confession. It's like, well, Roy. Yeah. But then this just keeps building, right? And it's further fleshed out in the first ever The Office webisodes, Jenna. Yeah. So the webisodes were called The Books Don't Balance. It featured the accounting department. And if you watch it, go to episode five titled Someone in the Warehouse. The accountants are wondering if maybe Roy took the missing money. Angela says absolutely not that he has too much character. And Kevin asks Angela if she has a crush on Roy. And Angela gets very, very flustered. Oh, whoa. She gets so flustered. She like, she like sort of messes up her words. And then she sort of storms off. And you can find this on the DVD set. It's on season two, disc four as a bonus
Roy, weird. Look, it's like a confession. It's like, well, Roy. Yeah. But then this just keeps building, right? And it's further fleshed out in the first ever The Office webisodes, Jenna. Yeah. So the webisodes were called The Books Don't Balance. It featured the accounting department. And if you watch it, go to episode five titled Someone in the Warehouse. The accountants are wondering if maybe Roy took the missing money. Angela says absolutely not that he has too much character. And Kevin asks Angela if she has a crush on Roy. And Angela gets very, very flustered. Oh, whoa. She gets so flustered. She like, she like sort of messes up her words. And then she sort of storms off. And you can find this on the DVD set. It's on season two, disc four as a bonus|||Roy, weird. Look, it's like a confession. It's like, well, Roy. Yeah. But then this just keeps building, right? And it's further fleshed out in the first ever The Office webisodes, Jenna. Yeah. So the webisodes were called The Books Don't Balance. It featured the accounting department. And if you watch it, go to episode five titled Someone in the Warehouse. The accountants are wondering if maybe Roy took the missing money. Angela says absolutely not that he has too much character. And Kevin asks Angela if she has a crush on Roy. And Angela gets very, very flustered. Oh, whoa. She gets so flustered. She like, she like sort of messes up her words. And then she sort of storms off. And you can find this on the DVD set. It's on season two, disc four as a bonus
feature. But yeah. So that happens in the webisodes. Okay. Well, then in season two, Casino Night, there's a scene where Michael addresses the crowd in the casino. And he says, old friends, new lovers. And if you look in the background, Angela and Roy are sitting next to each other at the bar. And you guys kind of exchange a look. I know. This is one of the things that's been pointed out on the message boards. What's the look between Angela and Roy at Casino Night when Michael says new lovers? And why are they sitting next to each other? Right? Why are they? I don't know. And then of course, in this episode branch closing, we have the scene at 10 minutes, 33 seconds, where Angela, like we said, is trying to confront Roy, tells him he's strong and capable.
feature. But yeah. So that happens in the webisodes. Okay. Well, then in season two, Casino Night, there's a scene where Michael addresses the crowd in the casino. And he says, old friends, new lovers. And if you look in the background, Angela and Roy are sitting next to each other at the bar. And you guys kind of exchange a look. I know. This is one of the things that's been pointed out on the message boards. What's the look between Angela and Roy at Casino Night when Michael says new lovers? And why are they sitting next to each other? Right? Why are they? I don't know. And then of course, in this episode branch closing, we have the scene at 10 minutes, 33 seconds, where Angela, like we said, is trying to confront Roy, tells him he's strong and capable.|||feature. But yeah. So that happens in the webisodes. Okay. Well, then in season two, Casino Night, there's a scene where Michael addresses the crowd in the casino. And he says, old friends, new lovers. And if you look in the background, Angela and Roy are sitting next to each other at the bar. And you guys kind of exchange a look. I know. This is one of the things that's been pointed out on the message boards. What's the look between Angela and Roy at Casino Night when Michael says new lovers? And why are they sitting next to each other? Right? Why are they? I don't know. And then of course, in this episode branch closing, we have the scene at 10 minutes, 33 seconds, where Angela, like we said, is trying to confront Roy, tells him he's strong and capable.
Yes. And then also, if we skip forward to the cocktails episode in season three, you will briefly hear audio of Roy asking everybody at the bar if they want to drink. And you can hear Angela say something like, oh, no, thank you, Roy. I'm and everybody thinks that maybe that's your character kind of coyly talking to Roy. Yeah, it's kind of odd that it's left in if you watch it because I'm it's off camera. And I'm like, oh, no, Roy, I'm and it just kind of trails off. So it's like, what is that about? And then my personal favorite in the episode, the negotiation. This is also season three. Roy is coming in to get his very last paycheck. And Angela keeps having everyone in the office retell her about the moment Roy tried to attack
Yes. And then also, if we skip forward to the cocktails episode in season three, you will briefly hear audio of Roy asking everybody at the bar if they want to drink. And you can hear Angela say something like, oh, no, thank you, Roy. I'm and everybody thinks that maybe that's your character kind of coyly talking to Roy. Yeah, it's kind of odd that it's left in if you watch it because I'm it's off camera. And I'm like, oh, no, Roy, I'm and it just kind of trails off. So it's like, what is that about? And then my personal favorite in the episode, the negotiation. This is also season three. Roy is coming in to get his very last paycheck. And Angela keeps having everyone in the office retell her about the moment Roy tried to attack|||Yes. And then also, if we skip forward to the cocktails episode in season three, you will briefly hear audio of Roy asking everybody at the bar if they want to drink. And you can hear Angela say something like, oh, no, thank you, Roy. I'm and everybody thinks that maybe that's your character kind of coyly talking to Roy. Yeah, it's kind of odd that it's left in if you watch it because I'm it's off camera. And I'm like, oh, no, Roy, I'm and it just kind of trails off. So it's like, what is that about? And then my personal favorite in the episode, the negotiation. This is also season three. Roy is coming in to get his very last paycheck. And Angela keeps having everyone in the office retell her about the moment Roy tried to attack
Jim and Dwight intervened. I mean, there's a scuffle and she just keeps wanting to hear about the scuffle. And it seems like she's just as turned on by Dwight's like being a hero as by Roy sort of being this aggressive dude. Well, this is Angela, the character's fascination with a sort of alpha male display of, I don't know what you would call it, just testosterone. She loves a big display of testosterone. Yes, don't forget, she mentions that she has had two men have duels over her. Yes, she loves all of this. She loves all of it. Roy is 100% in her wheelhouse. Okay, so we've tracked it. But Angela, you went to Greg and to Paul, the writers to get their intentions behind this whole thing. What did they tell you? Okay, yes, I went to Paul because he wrote the
Jim and Dwight intervened. I mean, there's a scuffle and she just keeps wanting to hear about the scuffle. And it seems like she's just as turned on by Dwight's like being a hero as by Roy sort of being this aggressive dude. Well, this is Angela, the character's fascination with a sort of alpha male display of, I don't know what you would call it, just testosterone. She loves a big display of testosterone. Yes, don't forget, she mentions that she has had two men have duels over her. Yes, she loves all of this. She loves all of it. Roy is 100% in her wheelhouse. Okay, so we've tracked it. But Angela, you went to Greg and to Paul, the writers to get their intentions behind this whole thing. What did they tell you? Okay, yes, I went to Paul because he wrote the|||Jim and Dwight intervened. I mean, there's a scuffle and she just keeps wanting to hear about the scuffle. And it seems like she's just as turned on by Dwight's like being a hero as by Roy sort of being this aggressive dude. Well, this is Angela, the character's fascination with a sort of alpha male display of, I don't know what you would call it, just testosterone. She loves a big display of testosterone. Yes, don't forget, she mentions that she has had two men have duels over her. Yes, she loves all of this. She loves all of it. Roy is 100% in her wheelhouse. Okay, so we've tracked it. But Angela, you went to Greg and to Paul, the writers to get their intentions behind this whole thing. What did they tell you? Okay, yes, I went to Paul because he wrote the
webisodes and it is so plainly spelled out that Angela has a thing for him in those. And I went to Greg as well, because I just felt like he had this overall view of everyone's relationships. This is what Paul said. We never really entertained it going anywhere. We just thought it was funny that Angela liked this rougher, less tolerant guy when the rest of the world was thinking he's kind of a jerk. And they're all rooting for Jim. So they sort of liked that foil, right? That I was team Roy. And then this is what Greg said. Greg said, Roy and Pam were more of a traditional relationship and Pam needed a more modern, equal relationship. But it made sense that Angela would be attracted to Roy. It could have turned into something, but Roy had to get in line behind
webisodes and it is so plainly spelled out that Angela has a thing for him in those. And I went to Greg as well, because I just felt like he had this overall view of everyone's relationships. This is what Paul said. We never really entertained it going anywhere. We just thought it was funny that Angela liked this rougher, less tolerant guy when the rest of the world was thinking he's kind of a jerk. And they're all rooting for Jim. So they sort of liked that foil, right? That I was team Roy. And then this is what Greg said. Greg said, Roy and Pam were more of a traditional relationship and Pam needed a more modern, equal relationship. But it made sense that Angela would be attracted to Roy. It could have turned into something, but Roy had to get in line behind|||webisodes and it is so plainly spelled out that Angela has a thing for him in those. And I went to Greg as well, because I just felt like he had this overall view of everyone's relationships. This is what Paul said. We never really entertained it going anywhere. We just thought it was funny that Angela liked this rougher, less tolerant guy when the rest of the world was thinking he's kind of a jerk. And they're all rooting for Jim. So they sort of liked that foil, right? That I was team Roy. And then this is what Greg said. Greg said, Roy and Pam were more of a traditional relationship and Pam needed a more modern, equal relationship. But it made sense that Angela would be attracted to Roy. It could have turned into something, but Roy had to get in line behind
Dwight and Andy. I love it. Oh, I love it. All right, so then Michael is down in the warehouse. He's talking to Darrell. He finds out that Bob Vance has bought the warehouse. And Michael really starts to spin out. And he tells the office he is not going to take this lying down. He and Dwight, they are going to go confront the CFO and they're going to save the branch. How? What do they think they're going to do? But I do have an old tech alert, old tech track at 12 minutes, 50 seconds. Dwight says, Hey, he's, you know, David Wallace isn't in the office. Don't worry. I have his home address and he goes to his flip phone. Jenna, do you see how he has to toggle to find the addresses? Do you remember that? Yes. And then
Dwight and Andy. I love it. Oh, I love it. All right, so then Michael is down in the warehouse. He's talking to Darrell. He finds out that Bob Vance has bought the warehouse. And Michael really starts to spin out. And he tells the office he is not going to take this lying down. He and Dwight, they are going to go confront the CFO and they're going to save the branch. How? What do they think they're going to do? But I do have an old tech alert, old tech track at 12 minutes, 50 seconds. Dwight says, Hey, he's, you know, David Wallace isn't in the office. Don't worry. I have his home address and he goes to his flip phone. Jenna, do you see how he has to toggle to find the addresses? Do you remember that? Yes. And then|||Dwight and Andy. I love it. Oh, I love it. All right, so then Michael is down in the warehouse. He's talking to Darrell. He finds out that Bob Vance has bought the warehouse. And Michael really starts to spin out. And he tells the office he is not going to take this lying down. He and Dwight, they are going to go confront the CFO and they're going to save the branch. How? What do they think they're going to do? But I do have an old tech alert, old tech track at 12 minutes, 50 seconds. Dwight says, Hey, he's, you know, David Wallace isn't in the office. Don't worry. I have his home address and he goes to his flip phone. Jenna, do you see how he has to toggle to find the addresses? Do you remember that? Yes. And then
he says, don't worry. He's on my Christmas card list. I loved this so much, Jenna. I love to think about what is Dwight's Christmas card? What is he sending out? It must be a picture of the beet farm. I feel like it's in some way also a piece of advertising. Maybe it's Mo's holding up a bunch of beats. I have a fan catch from Nico Martin. When Michael and Dwight are driving to David Wallace's house, the temperature in the car says it's 80 degrees outside. Why are Michael and Dwight wearing trench coats? Well, Nico, that's because we shot this episode in August, but it aired on November 9th. And we always tried to match the season in which the episode would air. So that is also why you're going to see pumpkins outside at Davis Wallace's house. We placed them
he says, don't worry. He's on my Christmas card list. I loved this so much, Jenna. I love to think about what is Dwight's Christmas card? What is he sending out? It must be a picture of the beet farm. I feel like it's in some way also a piece of advertising. Maybe it's Mo's holding up a bunch of beats. I have a fan catch from Nico Martin. When Michael and Dwight are driving to David Wallace's house, the temperature in the car says it's 80 degrees outside. Why are Michael and Dwight wearing trench coats? Well, Nico, that's because we shot this episode in August, but it aired on November 9th. And we always tried to match the season in which the episode would air. So that is also why you're going to see pumpkins outside at Davis Wallace's house. We placed them|||he says, don't worry. He's on my Christmas card list. I loved this so much, Jenna. I love to think about what is Dwight's Christmas card? What is he sending out? It must be a picture of the beet farm. I feel like it's in some way also a piece of advertising. Maybe it's Mo's holding up a bunch of beats. I have a fan catch from Nico Martin. When Michael and Dwight are driving to David Wallace's house, the temperature in the car says it's 80 degrees outside. Why are Michael and Dwight wearing trench coats? Well, Nico, that's because we shot this episode in August, but it aired on November 9th. And we always tried to match the season in which the episode would air. So that is also why you're going to see pumpkins outside at Davis Wallace's house. We placed them
there even though it was August to make it seem like it was fall. Yeah. We placed them there and hoped they wouldn't explode from the heat. Well, let's talk a little bit about the CFO's house because we got a lot of questions about it. It's a very nice house. We filmed there. I was, I did a few episodes there and it's a really beautiful home. Well, well, well, I'm rubbing off on you. I know. Charlene Guevara asked, was that someone's actual house or was it random? And Dixie Hydrix said whose home was used as David Wallace's house and where was it located? Well, of course, I went to Kentopedia and he told me that David Wallace's house is located on Lomita Drive in Pasadena, California. It's a beautiful neighborhood.
即使当时是八月，他们还是把它摆在那儿，好让它看起来像秋天。对啊。我们把它们放在那儿，只希望它们不会被热浪烤炸了。好吧，我们来聊聊首席财务官的房子，因为我们收到了很多关于它的提问。那是一栋非常漂亮的房子。我们在那里拍过戏。我曾在那里拍过几集，它真的是个很美丽的家。好吧，好吧，我真是被你同化了。我知道。查琳·格瓦拉问，那是某人的真实住宅，还是随便找的？黛西·海德里克斯说，谁的家被用作大卫·华莱士的房子？它位于哪里？当然啦，我去了肯托百科，他告诉我大卫·华莱士的房子位于加利福尼亚州帕萨迪纳的洛米塔大道。那是一个美丽的社区。
Oh, it's a beautiful neighborhood. It was three houses away from the house used on the TV show Benson. That's just a little bit of trivia for it. So just a little bit more about this house, Jennifer Hodge and Whitney Grasic wrote in and said, at 14 minutes, 13 seconds, why does David Wallace have an H monogrammed welcome mat? Shouldn't it be a W? And Anna Worthington said, are they at the wrong house? Is that part of the joke? Did Dwight and Michael go to the wrong house and that's why there's an H instead of a W? Well, Kent told me that it was the doormat of the people who owned the house and no one noticed the mistake until after they were in the editing room. And you'll see in the future, this is David Wallace's house. They just forgot to replace the welcome
哦，那是个美丽的社区。它距离电视剧《本森》里使用的那栋房子只有三条街的距离。这只是关于它的一小段趣事。关于这栋房子，詹妮弗·霍奇和惠特尼·格拉西克写信问道：在14分13秒时，为什么大卫·华莱士有一个印有字母H的欢迎地垫？难道不该是个W吗？安娜·沃辛顿说，他们是走错房子了吗？那是笑话的一部分吗？德怀特和迈克尔是不是走错房子了，所以才有个H而不是W？好吧，肯告诉我，那是房子主人的门垫，直到他们进入剪辑室后才有人注意到这个错误。你们以后会看到，这就是大卫·华莱士的房子。他们只是忘了换掉这个欢迎
mat. The welcome mat and also the golden retriever that's in the backyard. Oh, no, that's a whole story. That golden retriever was placed there. I'll get to it. Okay, well, I am intrigued, Jenna. So wrong doormat, but real dog will get to it. Maybe we should take a little break right now. And when we come back, guys, we have a really fun guest. Yeah. All right, we'll see you in a second. All right, guys, we are back and we are in Stamford. And Jan has called Jim and Josh into Josh's office. And she announces that Josh will be heading up what is now called Dunder Mifflin Northeast. Jim will be his number two. This is exciting news. Jim is excited until Josh says, Jan, I have actually accepted an offer from Staples. Yeah. And he's going to take it.
地垫。欢迎地垫还有后院里的那只金毛寻回犬。哦，不，那可是一大段故事。那只金毛寻回犬是摆在那儿的。我会讲到的。好吧，珍娜，我被勾起好奇心了。地垫弄错了，但狗是真的，我们待会儿会讲。也许我们现在该休息一下了。等我们回来时，伙计们，我们有一位非常有趣的嘉宾。好的。好吧，我们一会儿见。好的，伙计们，我们回来了，我们现在在斯坦福。简把吉姆和乔希叫进了乔希的办公室。她宣布乔希将负责现在被称为邓德·米弗林东北分公司的事宜。吉姆将成为他的副手。这是一个令人兴奋的消息。吉姆很兴奋，直到乔希说：简，其实我已经接受了史泰博的offer。对的。他打算去那里。
Senior management position at Staples. Jan is ticked off. She's like, you leveraged this new position to get the Staples job when we orchestrated this whole merger just so we could keep you. Yeah. So guys, this is it. This is the last time we see Josh Porter. This character has been with us for three seasons. He first came up in the pilot. We don't see him, but he's mentioned in a scene where Jan and Michael are talking about downsizing. We finally meet him on Valentine's Day. And now he's leaving. And guys, Josh Porter, we've talked about this before. It was played by Charles Eston. He appeared in eight episodes of the show. He did a weird pilot with Rainn Wilson. Yes. We never got to work with him, but he's an awesome guy. And to commemorate
史泰博的高级管理职位。简气坏了。她说：你利用这个新职位去拿史泰博的工作，而我们精心策划整个合并案分明就是为了留住你。对的。所以，伙计们，就是这样。这是我们最后一次见到乔希·波特。这个角色陪伴了我们三季。他最早出现在试播集中。我们没见到他，但简和迈克尔在讨论裁员时的一场戏里提到了他。我们最终在情人节那天见到了他。现在他要走了。伙计们，乔希·波特，我们之前讨论过。他由查尔斯·埃斯顿饰演。他在这部剧里出现了八集。他跟雷恩·威尔森拍过一个奇怪的试播集。是的。我们从没跟他一起工作过，但他是个超棒的人。为了纪念
his time on the show, we reached out to him and we got to chat with him a little bit. All right. We're so excited to have him here. Let's play the interview. Hey, it's Chip. Hey, Chip. Ain't no party like a Scranton party. Because a Scranton party don't stop. So great to see you. Thank you so much. Are you kidding me? It is so great to see you guys. You know how it is. You do a show with somebody and then there's just, you don't overlap again. And I'm in Nashville now. So I haven't been able to see you guys ever since then. And all I can say quickly is you could not have been kinder. Both of you were sincerely the only two nice people there. We know. Yeah.
他在剧中的时光，我们联系了他，并和他稍微聊了聊。好的。我们很高兴能邀请到他。让我们播放这段访谈吧。嘿，我是奇普。嘿，奇普。斯克兰顿的派对可真是无与伦比。因为斯克兰顿的派对永不停歇。很高兴见到你。非常感谢。你在开玩笑吗？见到你们太棒了。你知道是怎么回事。你和某人合作了一部剧，然后就没有再次重合的机会了。我现在在纳什维尔。所以自从那以后我就再也没能见到你们。我能简要说的是，你们简直不能再友好了。你们两个真心是那里仅有的两个好人。我们知道。是的。
Everybody was nice, but you two were remarkably so considering we had no scenes at all together, you were very, very kind and I appreciated it. We were so excited to have you guys and we, you know, Jen and I were talking about this, that we had major FOMO because it seemed like all these great stories were coming out of the Stamford branch and funny inside jokes who were like, dang it, we want to go to Stamford. Well, picture it from the other direction where you're the guy that gets to go be on the office, but you don't get to go in the office. You're in another branch somewhere and you don't get to, you don't get to be with everybody, but you do get to be with Jim and he was awesome. John was fantastic. And you got to wear fancy biker shorts.
每个人都很好，但考虑到我们根本没有对手戏，你们两个格外的好，我非常感激。我们很高兴能邀请到你们，你知道，简和我一直在聊这个，我们有极大的FOMO（错失恐惧症），因为感觉所有这些精彩的故事都出自斯坦福分公司，还有有趣的内部笑话，我们当时就想：可恶，我们也想去斯坦福。好吧，换个角度想象一下，你是那个得以参演《办公室》，但却进不了办公室的人。你在其他某个分公司，你不能和大家在一起，但你确实能和吉姆在一起，他太棒了。约翰棒极了。而且你还得穿时髦的骑行短裤。
Those were mine. I just showed up to work in those and no, yeah, I played the good boss. Well, you know, we've been trying to get ahold of you. Jenna was trying to slide into your DMS, but she must have jammed some other strangers. So you are not Chip Eston from Germany. No, I'm not. Charles underscore Eston. And I have so many famous leading ladies from classic sitcoms trying to talk to me on Instagram that I have. Yeah, it's so many. Okay, so we usually ask people on the show their origin story about how they came to be on the office, like what was their audition process? And we would love to hear yours. First of all, I was a British office fan, like so many from the very beginning. So I recall very, very well, watching it, loving it all.
那是我自己的。我只是穿着它们去上班，不，对，我扮演了一个好老板。嗯，你知道的，我们一直试图联系你。珍娜曾试图溜进你的私信，但她一定发错了人，发给其他陌生人了。所以你不是来自德国的奇普·埃斯顿。不，我不是。是查尔斯下划线埃斯顿。而且我有那么多来自经典情景喜剧的著名女主角试图在Instagram上跟我聊天，我确实有。是的，有好多。好吧，我们通常会问节目中的嘉宾关于他们加入《办公室》的起源故事，比如他们的试镜过程是怎样的？我们很想听听你的。首先，和许多人从一开始一样，我是英国版《办公室》的粉丝。所以我记得非常非常清楚，我看着它，爱极了这一切。
And then I heard they were trying into the United States and like a lot of people went, oh, wow, okay, good luck. But then I had known, then I heard about Steve and Rain that they had been cast. And I was like, hmm, that's, that's a heck of a good start. They might have a shot at this. Now, Steve, I don't know how I knew we just knew each other from being in LA for a while. I think improv circles, maybe something like that. I don't think we'd ever work together, but he's somebody I'd see at the mall. I love that you're seeing him at the mall. That tracks for Steve. Steve used to like talk to Jenna and I about like really good buys that he found over the weekend. Well, he was working at Brookstone at the time.
然后我听说他们正试图将其引入美国，就像很多人一样，觉得：哦，哇，好吧，祝你好运。但后来我听说，斯蒂夫和雷恩被选上了。当时我就想：嗯，这，这绝对是个极好的开始。他们可能真有机会。现在，斯蒂夫，我不知道我是怎么知道的，我们只是因为在洛杉矶呆了一段时间而认识彼此。我想是通过即兴表演圈子，大概类似的事情。我不认为我们曾一起工作过，但他是我在商场里会碰到的那种人。我喜欢你在商场里偶遇他这一点。这很符合斯蒂夫的风格。斯蒂夫过去常跟珍娜和我聊起他在周末发现的那些超划算的买货。哦，他当时在布鲁克斯通工作。
No, I'm not kidding. He wasn't. I was gonna be shocked. I was like, this is a piece of trivia I didn't know. He was trying to sell me a massage chair. No, he never, as far as I know, he never worked there. Anyway, I would see him. But the way I knew Rain is the interesting part that got me to the show. Rain and I, I'm going to say six or seven years, it's all a blur before that had been in an audition at NBC, you know, right across from the main place in Burbank was that little casting hut across the street there by the park. And we were reading for this thing called the Expendables and the Expendables were androids that solved crimes. These two guys, that's why they were expendable because who cares if they get, you
不，我没开玩笑。他没有。我当时会震惊的。我当时会想：这是我不知道的冷知识。他当时正试图向我推销一把按摩椅。不，据我所知，他从来没在那里工作过。不管怎样，我会碰到他。但我和雷恩相识的方式才是有趣的部分，正是这让我加入了这部剧。雷恩和我，我得说大约是六七年前，在这之前的一切都成了一片模糊，当时我们在NBC的一次试镜中认识，你知道的，就在伯班克主建筑街对面，公园旁边的那个小选角小屋里。我们在为一部名为《敢死队》的东西读剧本，而《敢死队》是负责破案的机器人。这两个家伙，这就是为什么他们是可抛弃的（Expendables），因为谁在意他们会不会被
know, you can't beat them. You can't defeat them. Chip, Chip, I did read about this. I did read about this and I got so tickled. So go on, go on. So I remember it was pure chance because they literally said you with you, you read with you because it was, it's two guys. And so they, they paired us up and somehow just kismet Rain and I got chosen to be together. And I remember forget we went outside and we had scripters. There was some things to say, but we went outside and said, let's just have fun with this. And by the time we came back in, first of all, I had fallen in love with the guy that is Rain Wilson instantly. We just clicked like that. I was like, what an incredible guy with a mind. And so we went in there and basically improvised on top of the script
你知道的，你打不倒他们。你无法击败他们。奇普，奇普，我确实读到过这个。我确实读到过这个，然后我笑得不行。所以继续，继续。所以我记得那纯粹是机缘巧合，因为他们字面意思上说“你跟这个人搭”，你跟对方搭戏，因为这是，这是两个人的事。所以他们把我们配了对，阴差阳错，我和雷恩被选中分在了一组。我记得忘不了我们走到外面，我们手里有剧本。有一些台词要说，但我们走到外面说，咱们就拿这个好好玩玩吧。当我们再次走进去的时候，首先，我立刻就爱上了雷恩·威尔森这个家伙。我们就像那样一拍即合。我当时就想：这是一个有着惊人头脑的不可思议的家伙。所以我们走进去，基本上在剧本的基础上进行了即兴发挥
and ended up getting the job. And then we all had a table read at NBC right across the street in the big building. I'll never forget there's this long conference table and we're all just reading the script. And we're still messing around. We're still just being these two androids and just looking very good. And so somehow we made it funny enough that they, they ended up shooting a pilot of it. And that's where I really got to hang with them the most. So in any event, we shoot that, we have a ball. It does not get picked up. Shocker. Shocker. So I get to the audition. And it's going well. I'm doing well enough, I guess, but I think the separating factor was one of them says, so I hear your, I think it was my, I hear your, your friends with Rain.
并最终得到了这份工作。然后我们在街对面的大楼里一起在NBC进行了围读。我永远不会忘记，那里有一张长长的会议桌，我们都在读剧本。我们还在胡闹。我们依然只是在扮演这两个机器人，并且表现得非常出色。所以不知怎么的，我们把它演得足够搞笑，以至于他们最终拍摄了它的试播集。那正是我真正和他们厮混得最多的地方。无论如何，我们拍了那个，我们玩得很开心。它没有被续订。意料之中。意料之中。所以我去参加试镜。并且进展顺利。我猜我做得足够好，但我认为分水岭在于其中一个人说：我听说你的，我想是我的，我听说你和雷恩是朋友。
And I was like, yes, I am. And I said, did Rain ever tell you how we met? And they're like, no, I bet he didn't. And I said, we met playing naked androids on a detective show. And they were both like, they're like, and I said, and on top of that, if you give me this job, I show up day one with a DVD of that pilot. I'm not even to my car. And I'm like, hello? Oh, cool. That's the fastest I ever got a job. So it had nothing to do with my abilities or acting. Otherwise it was purely that I had, I had this own rain. And so that's, that's my origin story. And it's kind of special to me because it's who could imagine by that point. I was already a fan. It was, it was like being on, it was like winning a radio contest to be on
而我当时说：是的，我是。然后我说：雷恩有没有跟你讲过我们是怎么认识的？他们就说：没有，我打赌他没说过。然后我说：我们是在一个侦探节目里扮演裸体机器人时认识的。他们两个都像那样：他们一脸震惊，然后我说：最重要的是，如果你把这份工作给我，我第一天上班就会带着那个试播集的DVD。我甚至还没走到车旁，我就在想：喂？哦，酷。这是我得到过最快的工作。所以这跟我的能力或演技毫无关系，纯粹是因为我拥有了另一个雷恩。所以，这就是我的起源故事。它对我有种特殊意义，因为谁能想到到了那个时候。我已经是粉丝了。这就好像在……这就好像赢得了一场电台比赛，得以加入
a show that I already loved. I was very uncool about it because I was just so happy to be there. But you guys were all very cool about it. So Chip, after you got the job and you started working on the show, we said like, it looked like you guys were having so much fun. What was it like to get to do these scenes with like Ed Helms and Steve Carell and Rashida Jones? Like, do you have any, any episodes in particular that you have fun memories of? There is the one episode where Josh gets very mad at Jim because Jim is playing Call of Duty and uses a sniper rifle and he's just started screaming at him. And, and of course Ed, it was amazing and that scene goes off. And so what I didn't realize is that everybody was playing that game for real on the breaks,
一个我本就深爱的节目。我当时表现得一点也不酷，因为我实在是太开心能去那里了。但你们所有人对此都非常酷。所以，奇普，在你得到这份工作并开始参与拍摄后，我们曾说，看起来你们玩得太开心了。能和埃德·海姆斯、斯蒂夫·卡瑞尔以及拉什达·琼斯这样的人演对手戏是什么感觉？比如，你有没有哪几集留下了特别美好的回忆？有那么一集，乔希对吉姆非常生气，因为吉姆在玩《使命召唤》，还用了狙击步枪，然后他就开始朝吉姆大喊大叫。当然还有埃德，那太棒了，那场戏就这么爆发了。所以我没有意识到的是，在休息期间，
on the set. Did you guys have that same thing in yours? I believe, right? Yeah. Your computers were actually hooked up and everybody was playing Call of Duty. So they just wrote it into the show. I hadn't played that much. I was like, now what rifle would they use? And they explained everything to me. And then we went and we did it and it was so much fun. Yeah. Our writers and editors were really into that. We didn't get to do that on set. We were always a little bummed, but they were playing it all the time. And on the DVD commentary, they did mention that John mentioned that's like one of the hardest times he had to work not to laugh was in that scene with you and Ed. And you guys were just going off on him about
片场上的每个人都在玩真的游戏。你们的片场也有那种情况吗？我想是的，对吧？对。你们的电脑实际上是连着网的，每个人都在玩《使命召唤》。所以他们直接把它写进了剧集里。我以前没怎么玩过。我当时想：现在他们会用什么步枪呢？然后他们向我解释了一切。接着我们去了，我们拍了那场戏，太有趣了。是的，我们的编剧和剪辑师对那个非常着迷。我们没能在片场玩那个。我们总是有点沮丧，但他们一直在玩。在DVD评论音轨中，他们确实提到过，约翰提到那是他极力克制自己不笑的最艰难时刻之一，就是在你和埃德的那场戏里。你们俩当时一直在冲他发飙关于
Call of Duty. That's the thing is you're in this business so long and you're in things that are pretty good. You're in things that are not good at all. And you're always, this funny thing after the show is I remember people would walk up to me and go, I saw you on the office. You're very funny. And I knew that what it really was, is I didn't say that many. I wasn't the funny part of, I was more of the situation than the comedy, but I did get some great, very, very funny lines. Here, I was just in a room with Ed and John and Rashida and trying not to laugh or just watching Michael Scott when he says, I love inside jokes. I like to be a part of one someday. That's just as good a line as anybody can write. And all I had to do was stand there and just do the thing
《使命召唤》。事情就是这样，你在这一行待了这么久，演过相当不错的作品。也演过完全不好的作品。然后总是会有这么一件有趣的事，剧集播出后，我记得人们会走到我面前说：我在《办公室》里看到过你。你真搞笑。我知道真实情况其实是，我说的话并不多。我不是喜剧的笑点所在，我更多的是处境而非喜剧本身，但我确实拿到了一些非常非常搞笑的台词。在这里，我只是和埃德、约翰以及拉什达在一个房间里，努力憋住不笑，或者只是看着迈克尔·斯科特说：我喜欢内部笑话。我希望有一天能成为其中一部分。这跟任何人能写出的台词一样精彩。我所需要做的就是站在那里，做出那种
where you don't laugh and you're kind of, you know, the cringe. And I couldn't believe I was. It was thrilling. Well, so what is it like for you now? Like the office has had this new life on Netflix and it's everywhere. Do you get stopped? Do you get recognized for being on the show? What it mostly is on social media is that I was on other things since and like when I was on Nashville, I played a character called Deacon and I was, people would watch it and it was a very dramatic, very sort of, he was in AA and he was trying not to drink anymore and he loved this woman. So it was always very dramatic, very heartfelt. Played music, did all these things. So inevitably, I would see a tweet that would say, just realized that Deacon from Nashville is Josh from Stanford.
你不会笑，而且你有点，你知道的，感到尴尬的表情。我简直不敢相信我在那里。这太令人兴奋了。那么，你现在感觉如何？比如《办公室》在Netflix上获得了新生，到处都是。你会被人拦下来吗？你会因为参演这部剧而被认出来吗？大多数情况下是在社交媒体上，因为我后来还拍过其他作品，比如当我拍《纳什维尔》时，我扮演了一个叫迪肯的角色，人们会看这部剧，这是一部非常戏剧化、非常感人的作品，他在戒酒协会（AA），正努力不再酗酒，而且他深爱着这个女人。所以它总是非常戏剧化、非常走心。弹奏音乐，做所有这些事情。因此难免地，我会看到一条推文写道：刚刚意识到《纳什维尔》里的迪肯就是斯坦福的乔希。
And then it always had that hashtag, mind blown. So that's mostly where it happened. It used to be that the office was a little bit more niche like somebody go, I know you're from the office, but now it's, you're right. There's just a resurgence. There's a second thing. The best evidence of that is my own kids. When I was doing the show, they were in junior high, elementary, maybe one of them was in high school. No, they weren't. They were in junior high. So they didn't know what the office was really. They didn't watch television at all. But now, going back, how many years has it been at this resurgence? Three years? More? Whatever it is. Oh gosh, it feels like in the last three or four years. Yeah, the last three years, I think. It was always
然后通常都会带上那个标签：大脑炸裂。所以这种情况大多发生在社交媒体上。以前《办公室》稍微小众一点，有人会说：我知道你来自《办公室》，但现在，你说得对。它迎来了一波复苏。有了第二次热潮。最好的证明就是我自己的孩子。当我拍这部剧时，他们还在初中、小学，也许其中一个在高中。不，他们不在。他们在初中。所以他们真的不知道《办公室》是什么。他们根本不看电视。但现在，回过头来看，这波复苏已经持续多少年了？三年？更多？不管怎样。哦天哪，感觉就像过去三四年的事。是的，我想是过去三年。它一直都在
on in our house. I think I told Angela it was on in the summer, more than the air conditioning. It was just, and they fell in love with it. They knew it so well. So that was maybe the first time when it was really cool that they, they, they were cool, chill about it, but yeah, you're on it. But I could tell it meant a lot. And it means a lot to me. That is so cool. The other rabbit hole I fall down with you guys is the, what do you call it? The bloopers, the bloopers on Netflix. If I start watching one, I'm there all the time. And I think that's because it's the best of remembering the parts to show you love so much, but then getting to see how authentically funny it struck you guys. Like sometimes you'd be watching you go, this is insane. They don't seem
我们家里播放。我想我告诉过安吉拉，它在夏天播放的时间比空调开着的时间还长。就是这样，他们爱上了它。他们对它太熟悉了。所以这可能是第一次真正酷的事情，他们，他们，他们对此表现得很酷、很淡定，但没错，你确实参演了。但我能看出它意义重大。这对我也意义重大。这太酷了。我和你们一起陷入的另一个深渊是，你们管它叫什么？NG镜头，Netflix上的NG镜头。如果我开始看一个，我就会一直在那儿看。我想这是因为它是重温你如此喜爱的剧集片段的最好方式，同时还能看到这些片段对你们产生了多么真实搞笑的触动。有时看着看着你会想：这太疯狂了。他们似乎
to think this is funny. I mean, I'm an actor and I would think that. And then you'd come away and you would see where everybody did break up at that line or where there would be lines that you just could not get out to save your life. And those always killed me. And also the scenes that never made it. I had a great scene with Malora that didn't, that didn't make it in. We were at the convention and at the end of the night, all this stuff is going on. I'm walking Jan and Josh are walking towards the elevators and basically Jan stops and invites Josh on up for the night. That's on the DVD set. She totally hits on you and you're like, nah, I'm good. Nah, I'm good. I'm good. I'm going to go to Staples.
不觉得这很好笑。我的意思是我是一个演员，我以前会这么想。然后你回过头来看，就会发现每个人都在那句台词笑场了，或者有些台词你拼了命也说不出来。那些总是把我逗死。还有那些最终被剪掉的戏。我和马洛拉有一场很棒的戏，没有，没有被剪进正片里。我们在大会上，到了深夜，发生了所有这些事情。我正走着，简和乔希正朝电梯走去，基本上简停下来，邀请乔希上去过夜。那段在DVD套装里。她完全是在向你调情，而你却说：不用了，我挺好的。不用了，我挺好的。我挺好的。我要去史泰博。
Exactly. I know you talked about how you were the good boss, but in this episode, at the end, you sort of serve up the ultimate betrayal and you leverage your job for a position at Staples. What did you think when you read that? Were you disappointed at all and Josh? Were you like, I get it. I mean, who wants to work with this group of loonies? At that point, I was just more disappointed for Chip than I was disappointed for Josh because I knew that Ed and Rashida were moving on over. And I knew it. I always knew that it wouldn't work to have the other boss there with him. I just saw something the other day, Janet, that like I've done a lot of drama. There are moments, the moment where he admires your
没错。我知道你谈过你是怎么当一个好老板的，但在这一集的结尾，你算是制造了终极背叛，你利用你的工作换取了史泰博的一个职位。当你读到这段时，你是怎么想的？你对乔希有任何失望吗？你会觉得：我懂。我的意思是谁想跟这群疯子一起工作？在那一刻，比起对乔希失望，我其实对奇普更感到失望，因为我知道埃德和拉什达要搬过去了。而且我心知肚明。我一直都知道让另一个老板和他在一块儿是行不通的。我前几天刚看到一幕，简，就像我演过很多正剧。有那么几个时刻，他极其欣赏你的
painting so much and he says, that's our office and you're just looking at him and you hug him. That's to me as emotional and as real and as heartbreaking as any drama anywhere. So that's another thing I've always loved about it and you guys. Oh yeah. For sure. I mean, Steve broke my heart many times on the show just with his sort of childlike innocence as Michael, even though he was a lot of times just a real like, I don't know, like idiot. Like he was also this very pure hearted person and complicated. Yeah. And I look now and I know how hard that is for writers. We've seen out things on different shows that go another season and another season. It's like, how do they keep it all together? Cause that's always the tension. When you have the full, when you have the
画作，然后他说：那是我们的办公室，而你只是看着他，然后你拥抱了他。对我来说，这和任何地方的任何正剧一样充满情感、真实且令人心碎。所以这也是我一直喜欢它和你们的另一个原因。哦，是的。肯定的。我的意思是由於迈克尔那种孩子般的纯真，史蒂夫在剧中多次让我心碎，尽管他很多时候真的像个，我不知道，就像个白痴。但他也是一个心地非常纯洁且复杂的人。是的。而我现在回看，我知道这对编剧来说有多难。我们看过不同剧集中又拍了一季又一季的内容。就像是：他们是怎么把这一切维系在一起的？因为这总是充满张力。当你拥有全面的、当你拥有
more honor people, what makes them funny is how out there they are. What makes them human is the grounding of that and giving up the other side, that tension between those two things. It's so hard to ride where you don't make them not funny anymore. Cause now they're just super human and kind and don't we love them. Or other times you just leave them like they don't have any arc at all. They're just that same person they always were. The way that they did that over the seasons with you guys is just, um, it's, it's very unusual and special. Well, your character of Josh had a great arc. I did. You thought I was the perfect guy. That is the other thing is that I always thought this is charismatic. It all comes very easy to him. Um, and in the end, uh, he does that.
更多古怪的角色时，让他们好笑的是他们的离谱程度。而让他们保持人性的则是这种基础的现实感，以及放弃另一面，这两者之间的那种张力。要做到这一点太难了，你不能让他们变得不再好笑，因为现在他们变得超级有人情味而且善良，难道我们不爱他们吗。或者在其他时候你干脆放任他们，让他们根本没有任何人物弧光。他们只是和以前一模一样的人。随着剧季的推进，他们对你们角色所做的那种处理简直是，嗯，非常罕见且特别。好吧，你的角色乔希有着非常棒的人物弧光。我确实有。你以为我是个完美的人。另一件事是，我一直以为这家伙充满魅力。一切对他来说都很容易。嗯，最后，他却做出了那种事。
Oh, I had one other fun thing. I, um, when Ed was on my final episode, Josh is the reason that branch is, is essentially going to be shutting down. So at that point, uh, he doesn't think he has a job anymore. He's just flipping out. Andy is. So there's that, there's a scene in the kitchen they had and all the scene was, was Andy walks in there. He's pouring some coffee or something. All of a sudden we get that first hint of that Andy Bernard anger that he later has to do it. And he just flips out and sort of destroys everything and stops. And that was the scene. And I was real proud because I said, what if Josh, the guy that's the cause of all it walked in right after that? And just to say goodbye, my guess is that Andy is not strong enough or brave enough
哦，我还有另一件有趣的事。我，嗯，当埃德参演我的最后一集时，乔希正是那家分公司最终将要倒闭的原因。所以在那个节点上，他觉得自己再也没有工作了。他简直要崩溃了。安迪就是这样。所以有一场他们在厨房里的戏，所有的戏份就是安迪走了进来。他正在倒咖啡什么的。突然我们看到了那种安迪·伯纳德式的愤怒的第一丝苗头，这是他后来必须要展现的。他直接崩溃了，把一切都砸了，然后停了下来。那就是那场戏。我当时真的很自豪，因为我说：如果乔希，也就是这一切的罪魁祸首，紧接着走了进来会怎么样？就只是来道别，我猜安迪没有足够的力量或勇气
to do anything, but go, great. It was awesome. Great. And just, you know, he would have to cover his fury immediately and be sort of the worst that he was in that moment. And, and they said, yeah, let's try that. So that was a lot of fun. He destroys that room and I walked in there and I go, listen, Andy, it's been great. And he's like, yeah, awesome. Good luck and everything like that. So that was very cool too. That was your pitch. I love that. I love that. You know, Chip, we talk about this a lot that we had this creative collaboration that we could in the moment pitch something to the writer on set and we were heard and that is so rare, truly. And we were so lucky to have that relationship with our writers. And I love that. We didn't know that. We didn't
去做别的任何事，只能说：太棒了。这太棒了。太棒了。然后，你知道的，他必须立刻掩饰住他的愤怒，并表现得像是他当时那种最糟糕的状态。他们说：行，我们试试看。所以那真的很有趣。他毁了那个房间，然后我走进去说：听着，安迪，这经历太棒了。而他却说：对啊，太棒了。祝你好运之类的。所以那也很酷。那是你提出的点子？我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。你知道的，奇普，我们经常聊起这一点，我们当时拥有这种创造性的合作关系，我们可以在现场当场向编剧提出一个点子，而且我们的意见会被倾听，这真的太罕见了。而且我们能和编剧建立这种关系真是太幸运了。我太喜欢了。我们当时不知道。我们并不知道
know that was your pitch. That's so cool. And also furthers the Andy character because Andy was always just white knuckling his anger, you know, and suppressing it until eventually, you know, he's going to punch the wall. But you love seeing him try to contain that such an Andy thing too. So that's kind of cool that I get to see that. And also the other thing, how cool is it when you have a little idea, a little pitch and you're surrounded by people that are going to make your pitch amazing. I've been in other places where you make a pitch and they try it and it just doesn't get sold the way that you had it in your head. But that got sold out and beyond anything I could imagine what he did with it. Totally did. And it absolutely just
那是你提的点子。这太酷了。而且这进一步丰满和深化了安迪这个角色，因为安迪总是强忍着他的怒火，你知道的，一直压抑着它，直到最终，你知道的，他会一拳砸向墙壁。但你就是喜欢看他努力克制这种情绪，这也是极具安迪特色的举动。所以能看到这一点真的很酷。还有另一件事，当你有一个小创意、一个小点子，并且周围都是能让你的点子变得惊艳无比的人时，这是多么酷的一件事啊。我曾在其他剧组呆过，在那里你提出了点子，他们尝试了，但呈现出来的效果就是不如你在脑海里构思的那么好。但那个点子被完美呈现了，甚至超出了我对他如何演绎它的任何想象。完全做到了。而且它绝对就是
crystallized who Andy was, you know, just all of that moment says who he is. That is fantastic. I love that story. Oh, Chip, thank you so much. Thank you for coming on here and sharing about your time on the office. We are so glad that we got ahold of you. Thank you guys. Where can we find you? Tell us where you are on Instagram. I'm at Charles underscore eston. I'm also Charles eston on Twitter and Facebook. And Chip, you're also you're on a show right now called Outer Banks on Netflix. Yeah, we were number one on Netflix. A little show called the office. For a quick minute there. Yeah, it's something else. It's really kind of amazing. We shot it last summer. It's sort of a young adult thrilling adventure. It has this amazing life on its own.
把安迪的为人体现得淋漓尽致，你知道的，那一刻的所有一切都展现了他是谁。这太棒了。我太喜欢这个故事了。哦，奇普，太感谢你了。谢谢你来到这里，和我们分享你在《办公室》度过的时光。我们很高兴能联系到你。谢谢你们。我们在哪里可以找到你？告诉我们你在Instagram上的账号。我是Charles下划线eston。我在Twitter和Facebook上也是Charles eston。奇普，你现在还在Netflix的一部叫《黑钱胜地》（译者注：实际为《外滩探秘》）的剧里。是的，我们在Netflix上排名第一。一个叫《办公室》的小节目。在那之前的一小会儿。是的，这太不可思议了。这真的很惊艳。我们是去年夏天拍的。它有点像一部年轻人的惊悚冒险片。它有着奇妙的生命力。
As I said it, we knocked Tiger King out of first place. Tiger King. That's something. That says something. And then I have one more thing to share with everyone. You do a weekly Saturday Facebook live stream. And it's called quarantine live stream. Is that right? Yeah, because of the show Nashville, I have to play out of music on that. So that's why I'm still here in Nashville. I get to do very cool things. I play at the Grand Ole Opry or the Bluebird or the Ryman. Oh, wow. And go around and make music. So I'm on Spotify too. But in any event, so I just play a couple songs on the show on the quarantine live stream. And then I do another thing where I do a duet with somebody. I send them video of me singing. They listen and
正如我所说，我们把《虎王》挤下了第一名。《虎王》？那可真不简单。这说明了一些问题。然后我还有一件事要和大家分享。你每周六都会做一个Facebook直播。它叫隔离直播。是这样吗？是的，因为有《纳什维尔》这部剧，我必须在上面弹奏很多音乐。这就是为什么我还留在这里，在纳什维尔。我能做很多很酷的事。我在大奥普里剧院、蓝鸟咖啡馆或莱曼礼堂演出。哦，天哪。到处跑着做音乐。所以我也在Spotify上。但无论如何，我只是在节目里在隔离直播中弹奏几首歌。然后我做另一件事，我和某人合唱。我把唱歌的视频发给他们。他们听并
sing along and we put them together in a video. So there's always a duet. And then I do interviews as well. Just like you're doing right here. Oh, this was last week. Yeah, last week was Old Dominion. The band Old Dominion interviewed. Well, Chip, thank you so much. It was such a delight. Thank you guys very much for having me. I love that you're doing this. Everybody loves that you're doing this. This thing is on fire. This podcast. Because what would they want more than discuss these things with you guys? So well done. And hopefully I get to see you down the road in some other situation. But thanks for having me. Thanks, Chip. We love you. Love you. Love you too. Bye guys. Bye. All right. So that was amazing. Thank you so much, Chip. It was that was really
跟着唱，然后我们把它们剪辑到一个视频里。所以总会有一首合唱。然后我也做采访。就像你现在做的一样。哦，这是上周的。对，上周是老多米尼恩（Old Dominion）。老多米尼恩乐队接受了采访。好吧，奇普，非常感谢。这真是太令人愉快了。非常感谢你们邀请我。我喜欢你们在做的事。每个人都喜欢你们在做的事。这个节目太火了。这个播客。因为还有什么比和你们讨论这些事情更让人向往的呢？干得好。希望以后能在其他场合见到你们。谢谢你们邀请我。谢谢，奇普。我们爱你。爱你。也爱你。拜拜，各位。拜拜。好吧。太棒了。非常感谢，奇普。这真的很
cool. I'm glad we were able to commemorate his time on the show. And to all of you other Chips slash Charles is out there that Jenna slid into your DMs. We apologize. That's right. Okay, Jenna, where are we? So Dwight and Michael are still outside of David Wallace's house. And they've decided that they're going to practice. They're going to role play what Michael is going to say when he sees David walking up, right? Yeah, they got to be prepared. Yes. So I traded some messages with Mike Sher and he told me that there was an element of the scene that was improvised. And it made everyone laugh so hard that they were able to keep it in, but they had to cut at this one moment because right after that moment, like one second after that moment, everyone started
酷。我很高兴我们能纪念他在剧中的时光。至于所有其他收到詹娜私信的奇普/查尔斯们，我们深表歉意。没错。好的，詹娜，我们到哪了？所以德怀特和迈克尔仍然在大卫·华莱士的房子外面。他们决定练习。他们要角色扮演当迈克尔看到大卫走过来时会说些什么，对吧？是的，他们得做好准备。是的。所以我跟迈克·舒尔交流过，他告诉我这个场景里有一个元素是即兴发挥的。大家笑得太厉害了，所以得以保留下来，但他们不得不切掉这个瞬间，因为就在那个瞬间之后，大概那个瞬间的一秒钟后，每个人都开始
breaking. So during this scene, when they're role playing Dwight is pretending to be David Wallace and he's doing a good job. He's making good arguments. So Michael gets frustrated. And he has this line where he says something like, just go back and start over and be more intimidated by me. Okay, that's where it was supposed to end. That was the scripted ending of the scene. But when they shot it, rain walks back in and Steve says, Mr. Wallace, rain goes, kind of like he's terrified. That was the moment Mike said it was amazing. And we literally couldn't go one frame later because they both started laughing hysterically. Yes, I love that because because Steve is Michael is like, be more scared of me and don't touch me. Yeah. It was so good.
笑场了。所以在这个场景中，当他们在排练时，德怀特假装是大卫·华莱士，他演得很好。他提出了很好的论据。所以迈克尔很沮丧。他有一句台词，大概是说，回去重新开始，对我更敬畏一点。好吧，本该到此结束。这是剧本中该场景的结尾。但当他们拍摄时，雷恩走了回来，史蒂夫说，华莱士先生，雷恩说，就好像他吓坏了。那就是迈克说的那一刻，太棒了，他们真的无法再往后延展一帧，因为他们俩都开始歇斯底里地大笑。是的，我喜欢这个，因为因为史蒂夫扮演的迈克尔就像是，对我更害怕一点，别碰我。是的。太棒了。
It was so good. All right. So now, lady, do you want me to tell you about this dog? Yes, I want you to tell me about the dog because I saw the doormat and I was like, oh, yeah, they just forgot. They forgot. And then I saw the dog and I was like, well, then that's, that's this people's dog, right? No, it's crazy. All right. So there's the scene where Dwight is sifting through the garbage. And by the way, this scene of him looking through the garbage, this was another one of those scenes that had been cut for the regular network airing of this episode. We got a ton of questions about this scene. Jocelyn Beecher wrote in and said, at 19 minutes at David Wallace's house, there's a dog in the yard. Did they
太棒了。好吧。那么，女士，你想让我跟你讲讲这只狗吗？是的，我想让你讲讲这只狗，因为我看到了那个门垫，然后我想，哦，是的，他们只是忘了。他们忘了。然后我看到了这只狗，然后我想，哦，那这就是这群人的狗对吧？不，太疯狂了。好吧。所以有个场景是德怀特在垃圾堆里翻找。顺便说一句，他翻找垃圾的这个场景是该剧常规电视播出时被剪掉的另一个场景。我们收到了大量关于这个场景的问题。乔斯琳·比彻写信说，在19分钟时，在大卫·华莱士的家里，院子里有一只狗。他们
specifically cast for a dog? Or did that dog belong to the people who own the house? All right. The dog in the backyard was something that they added. And they added it because they thought that there might be more of a feeling of jeopardy involved if there was like this guard dog or this watch dog standing behind Dwight as he sifted through the garbage. That was the friendliest looking dog ever. That dog was wagging its tail. It looked like it just wanted to play fetch. That dog made me want to get another dog and we already have two dogs and two cats. I mean, I know Kent told me they hired a dog trainer. They hired this dog and he was so sweet. He just wanted to play. He just wanted to like lick your hand that he was like in no way intimidating,
是专门为一只狗选角吗？还是那只狗属于房子的主人？好吧。后院的那只狗是他们后来加上去的。他们加上它是觉得，如果德怀特在垃圾堆里翻找时，身后站着这样一只看门狗或警犬，可能会更有危机感。那是见过最友好的狗了。那只狗一直在摇尾巴。它看起来只是想玩捡球游戏。那只狗让我想要再养一只狗，而我们已经有两只狗和两只猫了。我的意思是，我知道肯特告诉我他们雇了一个训狗师。他们雇了这只狗，它太可爱了。它只想要玩。它只想要舔你的手，它一点也不吓人，
just like you said. Yeah. But they stuck with it. They stuck with their like, this dog is going to be in the shot. We paid for this dog. Well, the dog looks so friendly to me. I just thought the owner's dog got out in the back of the shot and they left it in. That's what it looked like. Totally. All right. Well, listen, back in Scranton, Phyllis is bummed out. She's trying to organize a group lunch. Yeah. Yeah. And of course, you know, she goes to the Fun Stopper, Angela Martin, and they're throwing out some things. DJs, which by the way, DJs is a hoagie shop. And then there's Cajino's Italian family cuisine, right? And Angela's like, I don't want to drive to Dunmore. Jenna, I looked it up. Scranton to Dunmore, nine minutes.
就像你说的。是的。但他们坚持了下来。他们坚持了他们的想法，这只狗会出现在镜头里。我们为这只狗付过钱了。好吧，那只狗对我来说看起来太友好了。我只是以为是主人的狗跑到了镜头后面，然后他们就把它留下了。看起来就是这样。完全是这样。好吧，听着，回到斯克兰顿，菲利斯很不高兴。她正试图组织一个集体午餐。是的。是的。当然，你知道的，她去找了扫兴鬼安吉拉·马丁，而他们正在剔除一些选项。DJs，顺便说一句，DJs是一家潜艇堡三明治店。然后还有卡吉诺意大利家庭菜馆，对吧？安吉拉却说，我不想开车去邓莫尔。詹娜，我查过了。从斯克兰顿到邓莫尔，九分钟。
Oh. You don't want to drive nine minutes. Nine minutes. And then Kevin's like, what about Cooper's? And she's like, no, seafood. And I want you to know, Brian and I have been to Cooper's when we went to Scranton. And they gave us like a little hat that looks like lobster. What do you call them? Claws. Yeah. They gave us each hat. I have photos of Brian and I like drinking beers with these lobster claw hats on. It was really fun. But yeah, Angela Martin's very against seafood. And then I can't even believe Kevin suggests Hooters to her. Are you kidding me? I know. In the middle of all this, Phyllis just walks away. She's like, never mind. Yeah. You guys are the worst. Forget it. Yeah. At the same time, Creed is walking around. He's
哦。你不想开九分钟的车。九分钟。然后凯文说，库珀餐厅怎么样？她说，不，那是海鲜。我想让你知道，布赖恩和我去斯克兰顿的时候去过库珀餐厅。他们给了我们一个小帽子，看起来像龙虾。你们叫它什么？钳子。对。他们每人给我们一个帽子。我有我和布赖恩戴着这些龙虾钳帽子喝啤酒的照片。真的很有趣。但是，是的，安吉拉·马丁非常反对海鲜。然后我甚至不敢相信凯文向她建议去猫头鹰餐厅（Hooters）。你在开玩笑吗？我知道。在这一切当中，菲利斯直接走开了。她想，算了。是的。你们是最糟糕的。忘了吧。是的。与此同时，克里德在四处走动。他
dealing with this by selling everything in the office. He's selling the equipment, the fax machine, his personal computer. And I think if you look on the wall behind him, the dust buster off the wall. It's gone. I have a hair catch for Creed. I think this episode debuts a new hairstyle for Creed. It's poofy. It's like they blow dried it straight up in the air and then like used a rolling brush. I want you to look at his hair. It is so poofy. It made me laugh. Lady, I noticed the same thing. I had the same note. Creed hair? Yeah. I wrote down what's up with Creed's hair. Did they use the rolling brush on him? Like what's happening? We're going to have to track it because I want to see if that continues in future episodes. This new way of doing Creed's hair. The poofy.
通过卖办公室里的所有东西来应付这件事。他在卖设备、传真机、他的个人电脑。我想如果你看他身后的墙，墙上的除尘器。不见了。我有一个关于克里德发型的捕捉。我认为这一集展示了克里德的新发型。它是蓬松的。就像他们把它向上吹干，然后用了一个圆滚刷。我想让你看看他的头发。它是如此蓬松。把我逗笑了。女士，我也注意到了同样的事情。我也有同样的笔记。克里德的头发？我写下了克里德的头发怎么了。他们对他用了圆滚刷吗？到底怎么回事？我们得追踪一下，因为我想看看这在以后的剧集里会不会延续。克里德这种新发型。蓬松的。
It's so poofy. Yes. By the way, that whole storyline of Creed selling stuff, that was the other thing that was cut out originally and was added back for the extended cut. So the three main things were the Meredith storyline, this Creed storyline and Dwight going through the trash. Got it. With the friendly dog. Yes. With the friendly dog. All right. So now Jan enters. She's looking for Michael because things have changed. Josh Porter threw them for a loop. They've had to reorganize restructure and she wants to let him know that now Scranton is staying and Stanford is going to be merging into Scranton. Right? Yes. Yes. But Michael, Michael has been ignoring phone calls and a lady, we have some major
太蓬松了。是的。顺便说一句，克里德卖东西的整条故事线，是原本被剪掉而在加长版中被加回来的另一件事。所以三个主要的事情是梅雷迪思的故事线，这个克里德的故事线和德怀特翻垃圾。明白了。还有那只友好的狗。是的。还有那只友好的狗。好吧。现在简进来了。她在找迈克尔，因为情况变了。乔什·波特打乱了他们的计划。他们不得不进行重组重构，她想让他知道现在斯克兰顿要留下来，而斯坦福要并入斯克兰顿。对吧？是的。是的。但是迈克尔，迈克尔一直不接电话，而女士，我们有一些重大的
philisass. What's the philisass? Well, it is at 20 minutes, 40 seconds. She looks at Jan and she goes, we know the branch is closing. And she gives Jan the snarkiest look. It's so amazing. It cracked me up. And I was looking online for like sassy office moments. I just wanted to see if this had been clocked. Okay. On May 16th, 2020, which is just a few days ago from this recording, right? Yes. There is a new YouTube video collage that someone made called sassiest moments on YouTube, sassiest moments from the office. I think they have been listening to the podcast because all of a sudden there's the sassiest moments collage on YouTube. Angela, you 100% started sass. You started it early with Angela sass. And if anyone is out there using sass or
菲利斯式刻薄。什么是菲利斯式刻薄？好吧，在20分40秒时。她看着简说，我们知道分公司要关门了。她给了简一个极其讽刺的眼神。太棒了。把我逗乐了。我在网上搜索关于刻薄的办公室时刻。我只是想看看这个有没有被记录下来。好的。在2020年5月16日，也就是录制这个节目的几天前，对吧？是的。有人做了一个新的YouTube视频拼贴，叫做YouTube上最刻薄的时刻，《办公室》里最刻薄的时刻。我觉得他们一直在听播客，因为YouTube上突然出现了一个最刻薄时刻的拼贴视频。安吉拉，你百分之百开启了刻薄风潮。你很早就用安吉拉式的刻薄开启了它。如果有任何人现在还在使用刻薄或
sassing or referring to something as sass, I want everyone to know that you started it. 100% you should have trademarked it. Well, I just couldn't believe there's now, just now, like just this week, there's a YouTube collage called sassiest moments of the office. Anyway, there's major philisass here. So yes, Jan tells everyone the Scranton branch is safe for now. There's a lot of mixed emotions. Some people are really happy. Some people are sad. Kevin and Angela have a huge hug. Oh, lady, we got a fan question about that from Phoebe Tomak. When Kevin hugs Angela and picks her up, it looks like Angela got crushed a little bit and she wants to know if you got hurt. No, I did not get hurt. That was just, I think Brian having a little bit of fun
表现得刻薄，或者把什么东西称为刻薄，我想让大家知道是你开启的。100%你应该去注册个商标。好吧，我只是不敢相信现在，就在刚刚，就在这周，有一个名为《办公室》最刻薄时刻的YouTube拼贴视频。无论如何，这里有严重的菲利斯式刻薄。所以是的，简告诉大家斯克兰顿分公司暂时安全了。有很多复杂的感情。有些人真的很开心。有些人很难过。凯文和安吉拉紧紧相拥。哦，女士，我们收到了菲比·托马克关于这个的粉丝提问。当凯文拥抱安吉拉并把她抱起来时，看起来安吉拉被压得有点惨，她想知道你有没有受伤。不，我没有受伤。那只是，我觉得布赖恩在开玩笑
because he is such a big guy and he can pick me up really easily. And when would our characters ever hug or be this happy together? So that was just something he added. It wasn't in the script and he and I cracked up. I think you see me like, I think I'm genuinely laughing because it made us laugh. So also in the scene, Angela Pam asks Jan, is anyone coming back to Scranton? We know who she's thinking about. Yeah. And over in Stanford, Andy is asking Jim if he's going to go back to Scranton. And he sort of says he doesn't know yet. He's not sure. He's thinking about it. And then Ryan in the kitchen is like, I'm a little, you know, nervous about Jim coming back. I just hope it's not weird. Pam, of course, totally internalizes this. Like, oh my God, he knows. He
因为他是个大块头，他能很轻松地把我抱起来。而且我们的角色什么时候会拥抱或者在一起这么开心过？所以那只是他临时加的。剧本里没有，他和我都笑疯了。我想你看到我像，我觉得我是真的在笑，因为这让我们笑得很开心。所以在这一幕中，安吉拉潘问简，有人要回斯克兰顿吗？我们知道她在想谁。是的。而在斯坦福，安迪在问吉姆他是不是要回斯克兰顿。他有点说他现在还不知道。他不确定。他在考虑。然后厨房里的瑞恩说，我有点，你知道，对吉姆要回来感到紧张。我只希望不要觉得怪怪的。潘，当然，完全把这内化了。就像，天哪，他知道。他
knows. And he's like, I took his job. I sit at his desk. It's more about, it's all about him, right? Yeah. And so Pam's kind of relieved in that moment. Next, Ryan's going to have his talking head where he knows he'll be saying at Scranton. Here's the moment, 23 minutes, six seconds from here on out, all of the talking heads are facing back into the office. Oh, lady, this is your proudest podcast, Deep Dive Moment, maybe. Next, I think it is. I think this ranks right up there with your alpha womb deep dive. Oh, I did enjoy alpha womb. Yes, you did. Yes, you did. Then over in Stanford, Karen is saying, you know, she would move to Scranton if they offered it to her. Jim gives this poor woman so many mixed messages. Okay, I have some beef with Jim because he's like, why would you
知道。而且他就像，我抢了他的工作。我坐在他的桌子前。这更多的是关于，全都是关于他，对吧？是的。所以潘在那一刻有点如释重负。接下来，瑞恩将会有他的单采镜头，他知道他会在斯克兰顿。就是这个时刻，从这里开始23分6秒，所有的单采镜头都面向办公室内部。哦，女士，这可能是你最自豪的播客深度挖掘时刻了。接下来，我想是的。我认为这与你的“阿尔法子宫”深度挖掘并列第一。哦，我很享受“阿尔法子宫”。是的，你确实很享受。是的，你确实很享受。然后在斯坦福，凯伦在说，你知道，如果他们邀请她，她会搬到斯克兰顿。吉姆给这个可怜的女人发了太多混合信号。好吧，我对吉姆有些意见，因为他说，你为什么
do that? Just go to New York. I mean, you're 45 minutes from New York. Why would you go to Scranton? Right? And then he pivots back the other way at the end and tells her to take the job. I feel bad. I feel bad for her. I feel like these mixed messages are going to play out through the whole Jim-Karen relationship, actually. Yeah. Jim is very wishy-washy with her, in my opinion. In this scene at 23 minutes, 17 seconds, I have a Lee catch. Your husband Lee? My husband Lee. You're like, what other Lee am I talking about? Like, yes, my husband Lee. Okay. We watched this episode together and he said, oh my gosh, look at the sign behind Karen's head. During this conversation about whether or not she should move to Scranton,
要那样做？直接去纽约。我的意思是，你离纽约只有45分钟路程。你为什么要来斯克兰顿？对吧？然后他在最后又调转风向，让她接受这份工作。我感到难过。我为她感到难过。我觉得这些混合信号实际上会贯穿整个吉姆和凯伦的关系。是的。在我看来，吉姆对她非常优柔寡断。在23分17秒的这一幕中，我有一个李式捕捉。你的丈夫李？我的丈夫李。你就像，我在说哪个李？就像，是的，我的丈夫李。好吧。我们一起看了这一集，他说，哦，天哪，看凯伦头后面的标志。在这个关于她是否应该搬到斯克兰顿的对话中，
do you know what it says? No. It says, window of opportunity. An obstacle to one is an opportunity to another. Whoa. I just thought we thought this was interesting because I was showing him all the talking heads and he was like, oh, look at what's behind Karen. It's a window of opportunity. Layers, layers. Well, back in Scranton, Meredith is congratulating Creed on his business venture. He's made $1,200. And finally, Gary Trendle calls. He calls Meredith. Do you know why? He used to work at the Scranton branch and he says, I heard the branch was closing. Do you still want to make good on our agreement? Meredith found her guy. She did make a sex pact with someone. She almost confesses the branch isn't closing and then she's
你知道上面写着什么吗？不知道。上面写着，机遇之窗。一个人的障碍是另一个人的机遇。哇。我只是觉得我们觉得这很有趣，因为我正在给他看所有的单采镜头，然后他说，哦，看凯伦身后是什么。这是一个机遇之窗。层层叠叠。好吧，回到斯克兰顿，梅雷迪思在祝贺克里德的商业投资。他赚了1200美元。最后，加里·特伦德尔打电话来了。他给梅雷迪思打电话。你知道为什么吗？他以前在斯克兰顿分公司工作过，他说，我听说分公司要关门了。你还想兑现我们的协议吗？梅雷迪思找到了她的人。她确实和某人订下了性爱契约。她差点承认分公司没有关门，然后她又
like, can you meet me at my place in 20 minutes? We had a fan question from Bailey Aspinson at 24 minutes, 30 seconds when Meredith is talking on the phone. Who is she talking to? Do you know? Of course I don't know. Kent Sabornak. Finally, Kent. Kentopedia. Finally, Kent. Kent Sabornak played the voice of Gary Trendle. He was going to be my first guest. Yes. Yes. So Dwight and Michael are in the car and they're reminiscing now about their favorite memories of Dunder Mifflin because they've ignored phone calls and they don't know that their jobs are safe. And Dwight says to Michael, what's your favorite memory? And he goes, all of it, all of it. And then Dwight goes, even the part where the branch was closed and he's like, Dwight,
说，你能在20分钟内在我的地方见我吗？我们有一个来自贝利·阿斯宾逊的粉丝提问，在24分30秒时，当梅雷迪思在打电话时。她在跟谁说话？你知道吗？我当然不知道。肯特·萨博纳克。最后，肯特。肯特百科。最后，肯特。肯特·萨博纳克为加里·特伦德尔配音。他本来应该是我的第一位嘉宾。是的。是的。所以德怀特和迈克尔在车里，他们现在在回忆他们对邓德·米夫林的最爱回忆，因为他们一直不接电话，他们不知道他们的工作是安全的。德怀特对迈克尔说，你最喜欢的回忆是什么？他说，所有的，所有的。然后德怀特说，甚至包括分公司关闭的那部分？然后他说，德怀特，
was that part scripted when Rain said it was? Yes. Okay. That scene in the car is almost word for word scripted. All right. I didn't know if that was like Rain tagging the end of the scene. So I love that. It's so funny, Angela, because the reason I know that is because I had the same thought when I watched it and I checked. I wanted to know, is that scripted? Well, here's the thing we often could add a line at the end of a scene. That's the easiest place to improvise because it doesn't really mess up the context of the scene. So whenever I see these little throwaways at the end, especially by Steve and Rain, I always wonder. Yeah. Nope. That one was totally, totally scripted. Well, now we're back at Scranton and the gang is going out for shots. Creed is buying
雷恩说的那部分是剧本里的吗？是的。好吧。车里的那一幕几乎是逐字按照剧本拍的。好吧。我不知道那是不是雷恩在场景结尾加的戏。所以我喜欢那样。太搞笑了，安吉拉，我之所以知道是因为我看着它时也有同样的感受，我查证过了。我想知道，那是剧本里的吗？好吧，这里有个情况，我们经常可以在一个场景的结尾加一句台词。那是即兴发挥最简单的地方，因为它不会真正打乱场景的上下文。所以每当我在结尾看到这些小废话时，尤其是史蒂夫和雷恩说的，我总是很好奇。是的。不。那一个完全，完全是剧本写的。好吧，现在我们回到了斯克兰顿，大家要出去喝一杯。克里德请客
because Creed made some money today. Jenna, did you notice as Angela leaves what a big wave she gives to Roy? No, this is more, more of, more of Angela and Roy. Oh my gosh. It's almost awkward. It's almost awkward. At 26 minutes, 35 seconds, she walks by and literally goes like this. You guys can't see me, but I'm going to do it for Jenna. Oh, that's a big wave. Yes. It's a really big wave. So she for sure is like, buy handsome. Well, Pam now has her talking head facing into the office, I will say. And she is giddy. She's giddy. She's saying stuff like, oh, you know, it's good because finding another job is kind of a pain. And, and there are reasons to stay. But underneath all she is thinking is Jim is coming back, Jim is coming back, Jim is coming back, Jim
因为克里德今天赚了一些钱。詹娜，你注意到安吉拉离开时对罗伊挥手有多大吗？不，这更是，更多，更多关于安吉拉和罗伊的。哦，天哪。这几乎有点尴尬。几乎有点尴尬。在26分35秒时，她走过时字面意义上地做了这样一个动作。你们看不到我，但我会为詹娜做一下。哦，那是一个大挥手。是的。这是一个非常大的挥手。所以她绝对是在说，再见，帅哥。好吧，我要说的是，潘现在有了面向办公室内部的单采镜头。她欣喜若狂。她欣喜若狂。她说一些类似的话，哦，你知道的，这挺好的，因为找另一份工作有点麻烦。而且，有理由留下来。但在她内心深处，她想的全都是吉姆要回来了，吉姆要回来了，吉姆要回来了，吉姆
is coming back. That's everything, everything. And you're so excited for her. And then we go to Stamford and Jim tells Karen he thinks she should take a job in Scranton too. And Karen just lays it all out for the camera crew. She's just like, Hey, I'm happy you said that. I don't think he's into me, but I'm kind of into him. So there's that. Wow. This is like someone who's sort of unapologetically into this guy. I dig it about her. I like it. Jim doesn't even tell her apparently about what went on with Pam. So she's walking into Scranton. And she has no idea that he kissed the receptionist. He has, she has no idea that there was this four year flirtation. She's just like, I like this guy. I'm going to go to Scranton and see what happens.
要回来了。这就是一切，一切。你为她感到如此高兴。然后我们去到斯坦福，吉姆告诉凯伦他认为她也应该在斯克兰顿接受一份工作。凯伦直接向摄像团队全盘托出。她就像，嘿，我很高兴你这么说。我不认为他对我有意思，但我对他有点意思。所以就是这样。哇。这就像一个毫无歉意地对这个家伙有感觉的人。我很欣赏她这一点。我喜欢。吉姆显然甚至没有告诉她关于他和潘之间发生的事。所以她走进了斯克兰顿。她根本不知道他吻了前台接待员。她，她根本不知道有过四年的调情。她只是觉得，我喜欢这小伙子。我要去斯克兰顿看看会发生什么。
I'm going to take it one step more and say, she has no idea that he said, I love you. Hello. I love you to the receptionist. We are being very team Karen Philippelli right now. We are because Jim, Jim is spiraling. Let's be honest. I mean, listen, I can justify Jim's choices and his behavior. He has a broken heart. He's confused. He's crushed. We've all been wishy-washy. We've all, you know, we've all kind of done versions of this in our life and had versions of it done to us. All right. So moving on. Dwight and Michael are still outside David Wallace's house. He's never come home. It's dark. They're hungry, but Dwight won't let them leave. But finally he says, yes, we can go. And as they're leaving Dwight checks his phone,
我更进一步说，她根本不知道他说过，我爱你。你好。我对前台接待员说我爱你。我们现在真的是卡伦·菲利佩利战队了。我们是，因为吉姆，吉姆正在失控。老实说。我的意思是，听着，我可以为吉姆的选择和他的行为辩解。他有一颗破碎的心。他很困惑。他崩溃了。我们都曾优柔寡断过。我们都，你知道的，我们都在生活中做过类似的版本，也经历过别人对我们做类似的版本。好吧。所以继续。德怀特和迈克尔仍然在大卫·华莱士的房子外面。他从来没有回家。天黑了。他们饿了，但德怀特不让他们离开。但最终他说，好吧，我们可以走了。当他们离开时，德怀特检查了他的手机，
clearly gets a message that their jobs are safe and this is delightful. They're like, we did it. We did it. They're like, wait, they're like bumping chests. Yeah. But they literally are like, we did it. Like, what did they do? And even at the end, I think Steve is Michael is like, wait, what did we do? Like, yeah, how did this happen? I'm so confused. But I love it. I love it too. They're so happy. And then the whole episode ends with Toby saying, well, I guess I won't go to Costa Rica. I'll just, it'll be there when I'm 65. Yeah, exactly. Exactly. Oh, guys, there you have it. That's branch closing. That is branch closing. Guys, next week, we have a very special episode of Office Ladies. We are going to revisit our
显然收到了一条消息，说他们的工作很安全，这太令人高兴了。他们就像，我们成功了。我们成功了。他们就像，等等，他们就像是在碰胸庆祝。是的。但他们字面意义上就像，我们成功了。就像，他们做了什么？甚至在最后，我觉得史蒂夫扮演的迈克尔就像，等等，我们做了什么？就像，怎么会这样？我太困惑了。但我喜欢。我也很喜欢。他们太高兴了。然后整集以托比说结束，好吧，我想我不会去哥斯达黎加了。我只是，等我65岁时它还在那里。是的，没错。没错。哦，伙计们，你们看，这就是分公司关闭。这就是分公司关闭。伙计们，下周，我们有一个非常特别的《办公室女士》单集。我们要重温我们的
Casino Night episode with special guest, Ken Kwampus. Yes, the director is coming on to give us all of the behind the scenes stuff. This was such a big episode. And so many of you wrote in that we thought, let's revisit it with the director, answer some of your questions, and talk a little bit more about it. Thank you so much for calling in Chip. And thank you guys for tuning in. We'll see you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubakow. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad free versions
《赌场之夜》那一集，特邀嘉宾肯·クウォンプス（Ken Kwapis）。是的，导演要来给我们讲述所有幕后故事。这是如此重要的一集。你们有那么多人写信来，以至于我们想，让我们和导演一起重温它，回答你们的一些问题，并更多地讨论它。非常感谢你打电话来，芯片。谢谢你们收听。我们下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的声音工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布巴科夫。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版本的
of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。要获得Stitcher Premium的一个月免费试用，请使用代码office。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。